Hey Craig, you know now that I have a child a baby in the house.
嘿克雷格，你现在知道我家里有一个孩子了。
Do you know what I'm finding it hard to do?
你知道我觉得什么很难做到吗？
What?
什么？
To remember to do?
要记得做什么？
What's that?
那是什么？
Eat food.
吃食物。
Eat food, yes that's one of the basic needs that is no longer the priority.
吃东西，是的，这是基本需求之一，但不再是优先事项。
I know and I forget it's like oh I forgot to feed Nelson, my dog and myself.
我知道，但我忘记了，就像我忘记喂尼尔森、我的狗和我自己一样。
So, how are we going to solve that problem?
那么，我们要如何解决这个问题呢？
Well, I just need something quick on the go that I won't, no must, no fuss, I just need to feed myself and get some energy so I can get back to parenting.
好吧，我只是需要一些快速的东西，我不会，没有必要，没有大惊小怪，我只需要养活自己并获得一些能量，这样我就可以回去养育孩子了。
Yes.
是的。
And so, what would solve that problem?
那么，什么可以解决这个问题呢？
I'm going to steer you towards an outcome and the outcome is this product you're about to mention.
我将引导您走向一个结果，而这个结果就是您将要提到的这款产品。
Oh, wait, are you talking about Bavarian meets Little Lamb, Yeager, SnacksTicks?
哦，等等，你是在谈论巴伐利亚遇见小羔羊、耶格尔、SnacksTicks 吗？
The agreed that's what right before we started talking to Zoe said that's what we're going to talk about.
在我们开始与佐伊交谈之前，我们就同意这就是我们要讨论的内容。
Well this is what I want to talk about.
嗯，这就是我想谈的。
The great tasting Bavarian meats, Lil' Lan Yeager, Snacksticks, they sent us some of these and they are delicious and they solve the central problem of my life which is I forget to eat.
美味的巴伐利亚肉类、Lil' Lan Yeager、零食棒，他们给我们送来了一些，它们很美味，解决了我生活中的核心问题，那就是我忘记吃饭。
They're naturally fermented, they're made with real ingredients, slow smoked for bold flavor packed with 9 grams of protein per serving and have zero sugar and zero carbs.
它们是自然发酵的，采用真正的原料制成，缓慢熏制，味道浓郁，每份含有 9 克蛋白质，零糖和零碳水化合物。
Also, I have a 19 year old boy.
另外，我有一个19岁的男孩。
Also a good moment to get a bunch of this product because he will eat us out of house and home.
这也是购买一堆这种产品的好时机，因为他会把我们吃得满屋子和家里。
And he loves this stuff.
他喜欢这个东西。
It's so great.
太棒了。
I'm very grateful we got, we got to sample this.
我非常感激我们得到了这个，我们必须对此进行采样。
My son is gonna eat it all.
我儿子会把它全部吃掉。
I'm gonna have like none of it.
我什么都不会。
But okay, it's a snack that keeps up with your day, whether you're racing between meetings or feeding babies or 19 year olds, doing school drop off, just trying to finish your to-do list, take a moment to save or something delicious for you or your children.
但没关系，它是一种适合你一天的零食，无论你是在赶会议还是喂婴儿或 19 岁的孩子，放学，只是想完成你的待办事项清单，花点时间为你或你的孩子存钱或吃点美味的东西。
And did we mention they're portable?
我们有没有提到它们是便携式的？
toss a few in your glove box or gym bag, the diaper bag, wherever.
在您的手套箱或健身包、尿布包中或任何地方扔一些。
We have a diaper bag.
我们有一个尿布袋。
I bet you do.
我打赌你会的。
Better up to two or three of those bad boys.
最好是两个或三个坏男孩。
Pick up a pack today, your local grocer, or stock up at bavarianmeats.com slash podcast.
立即从当地杂货店购买一包，或在 bavarianmeats.com 斜线播客上购买。
Use code mother10mother10 at checkout for 10% off your first order.
结帐时使用代码 mother10mother10，首次订单可享受 10% 折扣。
The variant meat snack, sticks, great taste, zero sugar.
变种肉零食，棒，味道好，零糖。
I can talk for hours about every single episode of how I met your mother.
我可以谈论几个小时关于我如何遇见你母亲的每一件事。
And we do.
我们确实这么做了。
But when it comes to my own health, I used to be pretty clueless.
但当谈到我自己的健康时，我却一无所知。
I'd shrug off low energy, or a fitness plateau is just stress.
我会摆脱低能量的困扰，或者健身平台期只是压力。
Basically guessing about what my body actually needed.
基本上猜测我的身体实际需要什么。
But you shouldn't guess when it comes to your health.
但当涉及到您的健康时，您不应该猜测。
Instead, you should get the real data that supports your wellness with lab core on-demand health testing.
相反，您应该通过实验室核心按需健康测试来获取支持您健康的真实数据。
On the website, you can choose from a suite of more than 100 health tests, including micronutrient allergy, testosterone, fitness, sexual wellness, and more, all available to purchase without a doctor's appointment.
在该网站上，您可以从 100 多项健康测试中进行选择，包括微量营养素过敏、睾酮、健身、性健康等，所有这些都可以在无需医生预约的情况下购买。
Just purchase a test online, then visit a local lab core location to have your sample collected.
只需在线购买测试，然后访问当地实验室核心地点即可收集样本。
It's so simple.
就是这么简单。
With the days, you'll have accurate results that are easy to understand from a lab doctor's trust.
随着时间的推移，您将获得实验室医生信任的易于理解的准确结果。
For your journey, visit ondemand.labcore.com slash mother, and use code Mother to save up to 15% on select tests that's ondemand.labcore.com slash mother and use code Mother.
在您的旅程中，请访问 ondemand.labcore.comlash mother 并使用代码 Mother，在 ondemand.labcore.comlash mother 并使用代码 Mother 的精选测试中可节省高达 15% 的费用。
Know yourself.
了解你自己。
Hi, my name's Don.
嗨，我叫唐。
I'm from Manchester, originally, but I live in London now.
我来自曼彻斯特，但现在住在伦敦。
and Harmony Mother is one of the biggest parts of my life.
和谐母亲是我生命中最重要的部分之一。
It is my favourite show of all time.
这是我一直以来最喜欢的节目。
I even have a ducky tie tattoo on my arm, but it's also been a huge bond for me and my best friend Jamie.
我的手臂上什至有一条鸭子领带纹身，但这对我和我最好的朋友杰米来说也是一个巨大的纽带。
I'm getting married next year and I used Harmony Mother to ask him to be my best man by getting a cameo from Ranji, which was just so special.
我明年就要结婚了，我通过 Harmony Mother 邀请他当我的伴郎，让 Ranji 客串，这真是太特别了。
I just want to say thank you for creating the show it's absolutely amazing and I will continue to re-watch and re-watch and re-watch it until God knows when.
我只想说谢谢你创造了这个节目，它绝对令人惊叹，我会继续重新观看，重新观看，重新观看，直到上帝知道什么时候。
It's fantastic.
太棒了。
Is there something moving about hearing all the different accents?
听到各种不同的口音是不是很感动？
Like, to realize how globally this show just went out.
比如，要意识到这部剧刚刚在全球范围内播出。
You forget that because it was like we're on this little sound stage, you know, in West LA.
你会忘记这一点，因为我们就像在西洛杉矶的这个小摄影棚里。
And then this show just gets beamed all over of the world and all these people find it.
然后这个节目就传遍了世界各地，所有这些人都发现了它。
It's unbelievable.
真是难以置信。
Yeah, a couple of years after the show went off the air, it won this award at the Monte Carlo TV and Film Festival for being the most watched comedy in the world.
是的，该剧停播几年后，在蒙特卡洛电视电影节上获得了世界上收视率最高的喜剧奖。
It was a purely like metric-spaced award.
这纯粹是一个类似公制间距的奖项。
It wasn't the quality, wasn't on based on the quality.
这不是质量，不是基于质量。
It was just the most people watched your show.
这只是最多人观看你的节目。
Here's an award.
这是一个奖项。
And it was like, that was what it was for.
就好像，这就是它的目的。
It's like the Golden Globe Box Office award.
这就像金球奖票房奖。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
It was purely commercial that award.
该奖项纯粹是商业性的。
But it was the most watched internationally Yeah, that's measured well, thanks so much for that.
但它是国际上收视率最高的 是的，测量得很好，非常感谢。
We love here in these.
我们喜欢这里。
Keep sending them in.
继续送他们进来。
That's great Is there any world where we could get that cameo sent to us and we could post it on the show notes because I would love to see Marshall Manache doing a ranger based cameo.
太棒了，有没有什么世界可以让我们把客串发送给我们，我们可以把它贴在演出笔记上，因为我很想看到马歇尔·马纳奇做一个基于游侠的客串。
I did not know who's doing those You oh, yes, yes, yes, yes, right?
我不知道谁在做那些你哦，是的，是的，是的，是的，对吧？
This is That is the trick that I'm your favorite job I've met your mother, some is asking you.
这就是诀窍，我是你最喜欢的工作，我见过你妈妈，有人问你。
Would you please be the best man in his wedding try to make every moment of being together legend for it, wait for it, that is.
请你成为他婚礼上的伴郎，努力让在一起的每一刻都成为传奇，等待它，就是这样。
I'm alone, I'll be soon.
我一个人，很快我就会了。
In New York City, when I see you, please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
在纽约，当我见到你时，请允许我告诉你纽约的一切。
Hello, welcome to another episode of how we made your mother.
你好，欢迎收看我们如何造就你母亲的另一集。
I am Josh Radder.
我是乔什·雷德。
I am here with Craig Thomas.
我和克雷格·托马斯在一起。
Craig Thomas.
克雷格·托马斯.
I keep spacing on the name, but there was a lot of people on that show.
我在名字上保留了空格，但那个节目中有很多人。
Yeah.
是的。
drag crack Thomas my dear friend.
拖拉裂缝托马斯我亲爱的朋友。
We are going through every single episode of how I met your mother and we are figuring out what the hell was this thing we made that through most of our 30s for nearly a decade.
我们正在回顾我遇见你母亲的每一集，我们正在弄清楚这件事情到底是什么，我们在三十多岁的大部分时间里做了近十年的事情。
We're having a blast.
我们玩得很开心。
Are you having fun?
你玩得开心吗？
Oh yeah, big time.
哦，是的，大好时光。
Show it.
展示一下。
We'll show it.
我们会展示它。
Yeah.
是的。
I don't know.
我不知道。
Can I go again?
我可以再去一次吗？
Can I get another take?
我可以再拍一次吗？
We used to do a bunch of takes on him.
我们曾经对他做过很多尝试。
You would do seven or eight sometimes.
有时你会做七八个。
Yeah.
是的。
And then Pam would sometimes say, like, do it now, do it like professional actors, guys.
然后帕姆有时会说，就像，现在就做，像专业演员那样做，伙计们。
You know what I used to love that you would say sometimes you would say, I've, I know I've been good other times.
你知道我曾经喜欢什么，有时你会说，我，我知道我其他时候表现得很好。
I've been good.
我一直很好。
I've done good at the other shame of a bad take.
我在另一个糟糕的做法中做得很好。
Yeah.
是的。
I'd say listen, I've been good.
我会说听着，我一直很好。
I was good other times.
其他时候我都很好。
You would look around the entire stage and sort of address the crew.
你会环视整个舞台并向工作人员讲话。
I've been good other times.
我其他时候都很好。
And it will happen again.
而且这种事还会再次发生。
It may not be happening right now.
现在可能不会发生。
That's how it happened just that we all know it didn't just happen now.
事情就是这样发生的，只是我们都知道它不仅仅是现在发生的。
It didn't just say, but I you know it historically.
它不只是说，但我你从历史上就知道这一点。
I have it in the odds are I'll be good again.
我相信我会再次变得好起来。
Well, today, Craig, we are discussing episode two, purple giraffe.
好吧，今天，克雷格，我们正在讨论第二集，紫色长颈鹿。
Purple giraffe.
紫色长颈鹿。
we say so.
我们这么说。
It's a it that watching this episode, I felt, first of all, I really liked it.
看到这一集，我觉得，首先，我真的很喜欢它。
I really liked watching this episode.
我真的很喜欢看这一集。
I felt I re experienced the stress of the pressure of it needing to be good.
我觉得我重新经历了需要做好的压力。
And I will say that I remember having this fear the whole time that it wasn't good enough.
我要说的是，我记得一直以来我都担心这还不够好。
And that we were because the pilot, the pilot came out great.
我们是因为飞行员，飞行员表现出色。
I think I really, and I remember there's this pressure of like, okay, the conventional wisdom on an episode two is you're supposed to kind of redo the pilot and kind of move the story forward and show another couple of moves.
我想我真的，我记得有这样的压力，好吧，第二集的传统观点是你应该重做试播集，推动故事向前发展，并展示另外一些动作。
Right.
正确的。
And I remember being hard on myself.
我记得我对自己很严格。
I think Carter and I both felt like, how did that one come out as great as we wanted us to?
我想卡特和我都想，这个产品是如何达到我们想要的效果的呢？
I just remember having a little heaviness.
我只记得有一点沉重。
Like, was it the pressure of wanting it to be great?
就像，是因为想要变得伟大而有压力吗？
And watching it again now, so many years later, I was like, that's really good.
多年以后，现在再次观看它，我想，这真的很棒。
That did those two things.
就做到了这两件事。
It redid the pilot and moved the story forward and had this big task of getting Robin plausibly integrated into the group because she had not interacted with anybody but Ted in that first episode.
它重新设计了试播集，推动了故事的发展，并承担了让罗宾合理融入团队的艰巨任务，因为在第一集中，除了泰德之外，她没有与任何人互动。
And I was, I just felt myself aware of all of those challenges and I'm watching it.
我是，我只是觉得自己意识到了所有这些挑战，并且我正在关注它。
How did I feel you watching it?
你看的时候我感觉如何？
When I watched it, I kind of felt like it's pilot part two.
当我看的时候，我感觉这是第二部的试播集。
It's actually a two-parter of a pilot.
它实际上是一个飞行员的两部分。
It very much felt, it almost starts that way.
非常有感觉，几乎就是这样开始的。
It kind of starts like, where was I?
它开始就像，我在哪里？
And like, you're right back in and you recap, yeah, I did feel like the second half of a two-parter, which is great, which also kind of takes the pressure sure off it.
就像，你马上回来，回顾一下，是的，我确实感觉像是两部曲的后半部分，这很棒，这也减轻了压力。
I never realized how much it plays that way actually until rewatching it again now.
我从来没有意识到它实际上是这样播放的，直到现在再次重看。
Yeah.
是的。
Do you remember cracking this episode?
你还记得破解这一集吗？
So the pilot is just you and Carter, right?
所以飞行员就只有你和卡特，对吧？
And then you get people in the room, friends, you trust, joke, punch ups, all that.
然后你就会邀请到房间里的人，朋友，你信任的人，开玩笑，打架，等等。
With this one, you had a writing staff.
有了这个，你就拥有了一支写作人员。
Yeah.
是的。
You know what I found myself thinking of is that first album thing.
你知道我发现自己想到的是第一张专辑的事情。
I feel like you talk about the slouch, where a band has its entire life to do the first album.
我觉得你谈论的是无精打采，乐队用一生的时间来制作第一张专辑。
It's entire life history leads up to that first album and then they have to turn around a second album in like a year or two however whatever the timeframe is and we had our whole life kind of all these months to produce and make that pilot as good as we can make it and then all of a sudden it's like all right you're off to the races to show us picked up what's episode two and it felt like that challenge of like wait we put everything into that pilot how do we how do we bring this one around how do you make it anywhere near as good what's the first order is we how many do we get nine 12.
他们的整个生命史导致了第一张专辑，然后他们必须在大约一两年内扭转第二张专辑，但是无论时间框架如何，我们花了一生的时间来制作并尽我们所能地制作该试播集，然后突然之间，你就好像可以向我们展示第二集的内容，感觉就像等待我们将所有内容都投入到该试播集中，我们如何将这个试播集带到你如何制作它几乎同样好，第一个订单是我们有多少，我们得到九个12。
What's the first order?
第一个订单是什么？
I think we got picked up for 13 and then you're aiming for a back nine.
我想我们已经拿到了 13 分，然后你的目标是后九洞。
You're aiming, you're aiming 13 plus a back nine.
你的目标是，你的目标是 13 加上后九洞。
13 episodes.
13集。
I mean, they can cancel you at any point.
我的意思是，他们可以随时取消你的订单。
If they hit it, it's not doing well.
如果他们击中了，那就不好了。
But they, yeah, it's 13 and then you're going for that back nine pick up.
但他们，是的，现在是 13 杆，然后你就可以在后九洞接球了。
And that was I remember that band a big deal.
这就是我记得那个乐队的一件大事。
But it wasn't just episode two.
但这不仅仅是第二集。
It was episode two through 13.
这是第2集到第13集。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
Yeah.
是的。
And yeah, I just remember that feeling.
是的，我只记得那种感觉。
And we did.
我们做到了。
We hired a writing staff, we got in a room, we tried, it was, so this episode was our first moment of opening it up to create a story for the show with this group of people who were wonderful.
我们聘请了一名编剧人员，我们进了一个房间，我们尝试过，确实如此，所以这一集是我们第一次与这群很棒的人一起为节目创造一个故事。
We had a great writer's room, but we were, you know, we were figuring it out.
我们有一个很棒的作家室，但我们正在解决这个问题。
I remember it being hard, and we thought, I remember one of the things that sparked the idea for this episode was the Great Gatsby, that idea and the Great Gatsby.
我记得这很困难，我们想，我记得激发这一集想法的因素之一是《了不起的盖茨比》，那个想法和《了不起的盖茨比》。
Like any CBS that come in 2005, we were mostly working off the Great Gatsby.
与 2005 年推出的所有 CBS 一样，我们主要是在围绕《了不起的盖茨比》进行拍摄。
He's probably a Fitzgerald.
他可能是菲茨杰拉德。
All right, but we, I remember the idea coming in part from, the feeling isn't great, Gatsby.
好吧，但是我们，我记得这个想法部分来自，感觉不太好，盖茨比。
He's just throwing these huge, lavish parties, hoping that Daisy will come to one, right?
他只是举办这些盛大而奢华的派对，希望黛西能参加，对吗？
He's just hoping that by having this opulent mansion, it will be like a magnet that calls her over from her green light across the water.
他只是希望，通过拥有这座华丽的豪宅，它会像一块磁铁一样，从水面上的绿光中将她召唤过来。
And by the way, grew up on one of the eggs.
顺便说一下，他是靠其中一个鸡蛋长大的。
I grew up on what is East egg on Long Island, Port Washington.
我在华盛顿港长岛的东蛋长大。
And we think West egg was great.
我们认为西蛋很棒。
there's a little haggling about that between various towns in Long Island, but I'm standing by, but I grew up in East Ag.
长岛的各个城镇之间对此有一些争论，但我站在一边，但我是在东阿格长大的。
Not the fancy part.
不是花哨的部分。
I will say that.
我会这么说。
There's very lower middle class kind of upbringing, but their Gatsby was in the fancy part on the water.
他们的成长环境是中下层阶级，但他们的盖茨比却在水上度过了美好的时光。
In Sand's point, Port Washington thrown these parties hoping to lure Daisy across the way, and I felt feel like that was part of the idea of these parties.
在桑德的观点中，华盛顿港派出这些政党希望吸引黛西穿过道路，我觉得这是这些政党想法的一部分。
Ted's going to throw these parties, and it's going to learn Robin, and that was sort of the literary, the little literary spot.
泰德将举办这些聚会，它将学习罗宾，这有点文学，小文学点。
That's so great.
那太好了。
I had no idea, I wish I would have known that that would have been something that would really have delighted me.
我不知道，我希望我知道那会是一件真正让我高兴的事情。
Even though I never read the great Gatsby when I was supposed to, but about five years ago, I read it for the first time, and I, you know, you read something and you feel like you've discovered it.
尽管我从未在应该读的时候读过《了不起的盖茨比》，但大约五年前，我第一次读到它，我，你知道，你读了一些东西，你感觉你已经发现了它。
I was like, has anyone heard of this book, The Great Gatsby?
我想，有人听说过《了不起的盖茨比》这本书吗？
Unbelievable.
难以置信。
I was like, you guys really should have made this.
我当时想，你们真的应该做这个。
I really did think it was an incredible book.
我确实认为这是一本不可思议的书。
But so I'm curious.
但所以我很好奇。
So you and Carter, obviously you create these characters.
所以你和卡特显然是你创造了这些角色。
You have this thing I think going, you've been ordered for 13 more episodes at Leet.
我认为你有这件事，你已经在 Leet 订购了 13 集。
Well, you have this task ahead of you.
好吧，你面前有这个任务。
What did the writers, like, what did you stumble upon in the room for episode two that felt like really useful, like any eureka moments or like things that kind of made the story open up for you guys?
编剧们，比如，你在第二集的房间里偶然发现了什么，感觉真的很有用，比如任何灵光一现的时刻，或者类似让故事向你们敞开的东西？
Yeah, I think the idea, because I think we were something, we're in the realm of like Ted throws a big party and it goes wrong and it's a big party episode.
是的，我认为这个想法，因为我认为我们是一些东西，我们就像特德举办了一场盛大的派对，但出了问题，这是一场盛大的派对插曲。
And I remember feeling very afraid of that, because party scenes are hard to write, they're hard to shoot.
我记得我对此感到非常害怕，因为聚会场景很难写，也很难拍摄。
If the whole episode takes place at one big party, there's that kind of like loss of energy, right?
如果整个情节发生在一个大型聚会上，就会有一种能量流失的感觉，对吧？
There's this diffuse energy, there's all these extras.
有这种分散的能量，有所有这些额外的东西。
How do you make it feel like a himium episode?
你如何让它感觉像一个 hiium 剧集？
Like others, it comes, you do a party episode and it's all one big scene mostly.
和其他人一样，它来了，你拍了一场派对，大部分都是一个大场景。
And people pop in the shoe and pop in that room.
人们穿上鞋子，走进那个房间。
I was worried, it didn't really feel like our show or our pilot, which was jumping around in time.
我很担心，感觉不像我们的节目或试播集，它在时间上跳跃。
Lots of short scenes, cut, cut, cut.
很多短镜头，剪，剪，剪。
So I think the spark was, it's three parties.
所以我认为火花是由三个政党组成的。
It's three parties that sort of take place over three days and within that, we'll jump around a lot and we'll find ways to show that we're not just doing, like it's a sitcom episode with a party and it's mostly set there.
这是三天内举行的三场派对，在这期间，我们会跳来跳去，我们会找到方法来表明我们不仅仅是在做，就像这是一部有派对的情景喜剧，而且大部分都是在那里设置的。
I was thinking, I remember being very afraid of that.
我在想，我记得我对此非常害怕。
Afraid we'd lose energy and seem more linear and traditional if we did a party episode and episode two.
担心如果我们拍派对剧集和第二集，我们会失去活力，显得更加线性和传统。
I remember always, even once we got the idea of chopping up into three parties, I remember I never quite shook the fear that like has this just gonna be a wacky party episode.
我一直记得，即使我们有了分成三个派对的想法，我也记得我从来没有完全摆脱恐惧，担心这会成为一个古怪的派对插曲。
How do we make it different?
我们如何让它与众不同？
But right away in Act One, there's a bunch of playing with time, right?
但在第一幕中，就有很多时间玩弄，对吧？
There's like the fantasy of how the party's gonna go.
就像派对将如何进行的幻想。
And we see Ted's fantasy, and it's voiced over, and Ted's voice is doing all the voices.
我们看到了泰德的幻想，并且它是配音的，泰德的声音正在做所有的声音。
It's created into Robyn's voice, and you know, et cetera, Robyn says, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera, as Ted's voice over says that.
它被创造成罗宾的声音，你知道，等等，罗宾说，等等，等等，等等，正如泰德的画外音所说的那样。
And then Barney interrupts and hijacks and it becomes Barney's fantasy, and Ted turns to camera, breaks the fourth wall, and says Barney, But that was the moment in act one of that episode that I, and rewatching it, I really enjoyed that because it was like, that's the moment where it became a himium episode.
然后巴尼打断并劫持了它，它变成了巴尼的幻想，特德转向镜头，打破了第四面墙，并说巴尼，但那是我在那一集的第一幕中的时刻，重看它，我真的很喜欢，因为它就像是，那是它成为一集的时刻。
And I wrote you this little ditty to send you a new York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，是为了寄给你一个纽约市。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
You know, there was a time when I would ignore, or maybe not even notice, when my sheet started slipping off corners, or pilling, or when my pillows weren't quite as supportive as I wanted them to be.
你知道，曾经有一段时间，当我的床单开始从角落滑落或起球，或者当我的枕头不像我希望的那样支撑时，我会忽略，甚至可能没有注意到。
My wife, however, has always noticed this sort of thing.
然而，我的妻子总是注意到这种事情。
But now that we got a baby waking up at, you know, various times, every moment of sleep has become invaluable.
但现在我们有了一个婴儿，你知道，在不同的时间醒来，每一刻的睡眠都变得非常宝贵。
And I am so delighted that Bull and Branch sent us some of the comfiest sheets that I have have ever had the pleasure to sleep upon.
我很高兴 Bull 和 Branch 给我们送来了一些我睡过的最舒适的床单。
Their organic cotton bedding is designed for deep, uninterrupted rest, which is what we're getting.
他们的有机棉床上用品专为深度、不间断的休息而设计，这正是我们所得到的。
The sheets are incredibly soft, they're breathable, and it's a total game changer for our energy levels, especially with this young, occasionally sleeping baby we have now.
这些床单非常柔软，透气，它完全改变了我们的能量水平，尤其是对于我们现在这个偶尔睡觉的小婴儿来说。
This is the kind of comfort we can't afford to compromise anymore.
这是我们不能再妥协的舒适感。
Upgrade your sleep with bowl and branch, Get 15% off your first order plus free shipping at bullenbranch.com slash your mother with code, your mother, that's bullenbranch, B-O-L-L-A-N-D branch dot com slash your mother, code your mother to unlock 15% off exclusion's apply.
用碗和树枝升级您的睡眠，首次订单可享受 15% 折扣，并在 bullenbranch.com 免运费。用代码削减你的母亲，你的母亲，那就是 bullenbranch，B-O-L-L-A-N-D 分支 . com 削减你的母亲，代码你的母亲解锁排除适用的 15% 折扣。
Snapple would like you to take a break from the sheds, those things you should be doing should be finishing, should be thinking about.
斯内普尔希望你从棚子里休息一下，那些你应该做的事情应该完成，应该思考。
Well, right now, just, oh, crack open a Snapple, and just sit tight for a minute.
好吧，现在，只是，哦，打开一个 Snapple，然后坐一会儿。
Well, Craig and I share some Snapple real facts with you, not unlike Mr. Mosby's fun facts.
好吧，克雷格和我与您分享一些 Snapple 的真实事实，就像莫斯比先生的有趣事实一样。
Mr. Ted Mosby would have a lot of his fun facts.
特德·莫斯比先生会有很多有趣的事实。
He would love these, and some of these are even an architecture related.
他会喜欢这些，其中一些甚至与建筑相关。
So give us our first fact.
那么请告诉我们第一个事实。
What do you got?
你有什么？
These all feel like things Ted or at least like a future like dad Ted would say.
这些都感觉像是泰德的事情，或者至少像泰德爸爸所说的未来。
All right, here is a Snapple Real Facts, 253.
好吧，这是 Snapple 的真实事实，253。
The first TV remote control introduced in 1950 was called Lazy Bones.
1950 年推出的第一个电视遥控器被称为“Lazy Bones”。
I didn't know that.
我不知道。
I mean, I mean, either.
我的意思是，我的意思是，要么。
Real Facts, 1517 in New York, it is illegal to sell a haunted house without telling the buyer.
真实事实，1517年在纽约，在不告诉买家的情况下出售鬼屋是违法的。
That's actually amazing.
这实际上是惊人的。
And that feels like a very, that feels like a very martial actually.
这感觉就像是一种非常非常武术的感觉。
These are weirdly resonant.
这些产生了奇怪的共鸣。
Okay, fact, that is amazing and I want to know more but we don't have time for it in the past in the Snapple Chat, Real Facts 1978, 1,978 I'm gonna think of has nothing to do with the year 1978.
好吧，事实上，这太神奇了，我想了解更多，但我们过去在 Snapple Chat 中没有时间了解它，真实的事实 1978，我会想到 1,978 与 1978 年无关。
More than 40 buildings in New York have their own zip codes.
纽约有 40 多座建筑物都有自己的邮政编码。
That is totally a Ted Mosby fund.
这完全是泰德·莫斯比基金。
That is.
那是。
He would actually know that.
他实际上会知道这一点。
He told every girlfriend that.
他对每个女朋友都这么说。
Snapple Real Facts, 1,667.
斯纳普真实事实，1,667。
Lovebirds are actual birds.
爱情鸟是真正的鸟类。
Boom, and we bring it back to love.
繁荣，我们把它带回爱。
It's all full circle.
这都是完整的循环。
It's all very himmiumy.
这一切都非常有趣。
All right, that's your break.
好吧，这是你的休息时间。
Quick fun and just a little unexpected.
快速有趣，只是有点出乎意料。
next time you hit pause and make a count with Snapple on your next break.
下次您按下暂停键并在下一次休息时使用 Snapple 进行计数。
Hey, Alex!
嘿，亚历克斯！
Josh, remember those legendary freezer pops from childhood summers?
乔什，还记得童年夏天那些传奇的冰柜汽水吗？
You know the one I'm talking about, the red, white, and blue ones.
你知道我说的是红色、白色和蓝色的。
It is the only thing I remember from childhood.
这是我从小到大唯一记得的事情。
That's right.
这是正确的。
They pretty much ruled the neighborhood pools and playgrounds.
他们几乎统治着附近的游泳池和游乐场。
Your face would be covered with your finger, it was just a delightful summer memory.
你的脸会被你的手指遮住，那只是一个愉快的夏日记忆。
So five-hour energy has taken that iconic nostalgia and reimagined it as a bold, refreshing firework freeze energy shot.
因此，五小时的能量消除了标志性的怀旧情绪，并将其重新想象为大胆、清爽的烟花冻结能量镜头。
Every single sip delivers a massive flavor explosion like the original pops of which you speak, expertly blending juicy cherry, citrusy lime, and sweet blue raspberry to completely ignite your taste buds.
每一口都会带来巨大的风味爆炸，就像您所说的原始流行音乐一样，巧妙地混合了多汁的樱桃、柑橘酸橙和甜美的蓝覆盆子，完全点燃您的味蕾。
It's that fruity taste that you crave, created with zero sugar, so you can enjoy the full experience, guilt-free.
这是您渴望的果香味道，采用零糖打造，让您可以无负罪感地享受完整的体验。
Whether you're conquering a packed schedule, tackling a mid-afternoon slump at your desk, headed out on a weekend road trip or just looking to spark a vibrant new flavor sensation, this portable shot is the perfect daily companion.
无论您是要克服繁忙的日程、解决午后在办公桌前的困倦、周末公路旅行还是只是想激发一种充满活力的新风味，这款便携式镜头都是完美的日常伴侣。
Give your routine an exciting upgrade with a mouth-watering twist on a timeless favorite.
为您的日常生活带来令人兴奋的升级，为永恒的最爱带来令人垂涎的变化。
Ignite your taste buds with a firework freeze flavored five hour energy shot now available online at five hour energy dot com or Amazon.
烟花冷冻口味的五小时能量饮料点燃您的味蕾，现在可在五小时能量网站或亚马逊上购买。
And now back to the show.
现在回到节目。
And that's another interesting thing about the show while it's a very hard on it sleeves sincere show.
这是该节目的另一个有趣的事情，虽然它是一个非常努力的真诚节目。
It also had so many meta elements like it was a TV show that was aware it was a TV show and it was always like playing with structure and testing it up and saying.
它也有很多元元素，就像它是一个电视节目一样，它知道它是一个电视节目，它总是像玩弄结构并测试它并说。
or it was also aware of its own storytelling more than being a TV show, you know, like.
或者它也比电视节目更了解自己的故事讲述，你知道的。
Yeah.
是的。
Like, okay, we're gonna show you what he's clearly just saying at the bar, but we're gonna, we're gonna kind of flip it on his head and someone's gonna interrupt someone else's.
就像，好吧，我们会向你展示他在酒吧里清楚地说了什么，但我们会，我们会翻转他的头，然后有人会打断别人的。
They're just gonna like hijack someone's story in the middle of the story.
他们只是喜欢在故事中间劫持某人的故事。
I don't know, it's quite clever in that way.
我不知道，这很聪明。
I love that moment.
我喜欢那一刻。
I love, I forgot about Ted breaking the fourth wall.
我爱，我忘记了泰德打破第四堵墙。
I forgot about like you turn to camera and you just start talking to Barney through the TV screen.
我忘记了，就像你转向镜头，然后你就开始通过电视屏幕与巴尼交谈。
I forgot about the lip syncing where Ted is, it's his voice, you know, with all the other characters.
我忘记了泰德在哪里，这是他的声音，你知道，与所有其他角色。
I love that so much.
我非常喜欢这个。
Josh, I just want to, I just want to ask you a question about about the show.
乔希，我只是想，我只是想问你一个关于这个节目的问题。
So you get the pilot, you're on it.
所以你得到了飞行员，你就可以了。
You're actually making a pilot.
你实际上是在培养一名飞行员。
Then this show gets picked up.
然后这个节目就被收看了。
Now your life, you know, you hear stories out here of people who like move from across the country to be in this TV show they got.
现在，你知道，你的生活中，你会听到人们喜欢从全国各地搬来参加他们的电视节目的故事。
And then it gets canceled a couple of episodes in, or you give up your, your, your, your, you're waiting, you know, your, your, your server job, you're, you know, have a show.
然后它被取消了几集，或者你放弃你，你，你，你，你在等待，你知道，你，你，你的服务器工作，你，你知道，有一场演出。
Do you take that in?
你接受吗？
Can you not think of it in that way?
你能不这样想吗？
And do you just have to know to the grind?
你只需要知道到底吗？
So now I'm going to do this next episode.
所以现在我要在下一集做这个。
And we're going to, we're going to hope for the best.
我们会，我们会抱最好的希望。
What were you feeling now that maybe your life was changing quite a bit?
也许你的生活发生了很大的变化，你现在有什么感觉？
Well, it's tricky because you don't want to pop the champagne until you can afford the champagne.
嗯，这很棘手，因为除非你买得起香槟，否则你不想开香槟。
I do remember my, I had my first agent.
我确实记得我的，我有我的第一个经纪人。
I had, she signed me right out of grad school at NYU.
我从纽约大学研究生院毕业后，她就签下了我。
And I lived in New York for a while, but I was generally living mostly in LA and then I go back to New York and the summer and do a play like I was a little bit bicoswise, mostly live in New York.
我在纽约住了一段时间，但我通常主要住在洛杉矶，然后我回到纽约，夏天，就像我有点双向智慧一样，主要住在纽约。
And I had done a bunch of pilots and she always got me what's called a relocation fee because she said, no, he lives New York.
我做过很多试点，她总是给我所谓的搬迁费，因为她说，不，他住在纽约。
You have to pay to relocate him to LA.
你必须付费才能把他搬到洛杉矶。
She always built it into my deal.
她总是把它纳入我的交易中。
And she told me on how I met your mother, she had negotiated for me with this dealmaker before.
她告诉我我是怎么认识你母亲的，她以前曾为我和这个交易撮合者谈判过。
And she tried to get the relocation fee and the dealmaker said, Rhonda, we know he lives in LA, knock it off.
她试图拿到搬迁费，交易撮合者说，朗达，我们知道他住在洛杉矶，别闹了。
They weren't gonna give it to him.
他们不会把它给他。
Yeah.
是的。
So I was still in this $750 a month sublet.
所以我仍然住在每月 750 美元的转租合同中。
I was subletting from my friend Megan, a college friend of mine.
我是从我的大学朋友梅根那里转租的。
I didn't move until second season, And I think, so I kept things real modest.
直到第二季我才搬家，我想，所以我保持谦虚。
We lived right around, my best friends lived across the street.
我们就住在附近，我最好的朋友住在街对面。
We lived right by the CBS main corporate building where they shoot the prices right and all these other television city.
我们住在哥伦比亚广播公司 (CBS) 主公司大楼旁边，他们在那里制定正确的价格，还有其他所有电视城。
Is that what it's called on Beverly?
这就是贝弗利的名字吗？
Television city, yeah, I'm telling you.
电视城，是的，我告诉你。
And do you remember this, Craig?
你还记得这一点吗，克雷格？
They put up a huge how I met your mother.
他们大肆宣传我是如何认识你母亲的。
It was the lip couch.
这是嘴唇沙发。
It was me on the lip couch with the other four behind me.
我坐在沙发上，其他四个人在我身后。
and they put it up and they kept it up the entire season.
他们把它放了出来，并且整个赛季都保持着这样的状态。
They didn't take it down.
他们没有把它拿下来。
So I was always walking on Beverly Boulevard with my friends and it was just like this enormous mural of us on the side of this building on Beverly Boulevard.
所以我总是和朋友们一起走在比佛利大道上，就像比佛利大道这座建筑一侧的一幅巨大的壁画一样。
I didn't know that was right under this, basically.
基本上我不知道就在这下面。
That was really funny.
那真的很有趣。
I was one of the things where life just felt a little like, there was this, this, like, tincture of weirdness, like a solution of weirdness that got dropped into whatever I was living in.
我是那种生活感觉有点像，有这个，这个，就像，奇怪的酊剂，就像一种奇怪的解决方案，融入到我生活的任何地方。
And suddenly I was like, this is a little bit weirder.
突然我就想，这有点奇怪。
And then my friend Amy was like, oh I forgot that like people are gonna watch this show, we're gonna go out with you and it's gonna add a whole other element to our lives of people coming up and saying things to you or wanting a picture or whatever.
然后我的朋友艾米说，哦，我忘了，就像人们会看这个节目一样，我们会和你一起出去，这会给我们的生活添加一个全新的元素，人们会过来对你说一些话，或者想要一张照片或其他什么。
And it wasn't out of control back then.
而且当时还没有失控。
It was still we were finding our feet.
我们仍然在寻找立足点。
So I definitely had this feeling that there was the potential of my life getting kind of disorienting and strange and fun, you know?
所以我确实有这样的感觉，我的生活有可能变得有点迷失方向、变得奇怪和有趣，你知道吗？
I remember Julie who was one of our, the CBS executive, Julie, who it's great.
我记得朱莉，她是我们哥伦比亚广播公司的高管之一，朱莉，她很棒。
Hello, Julie, if you're listening.
你好，朱莉，如果你在听的话。
But Julie, I remember the premiere party saying, she said, how are you feeling?
但是朱莉，我记得首映式派对上她说，你感觉怎么样？
And I said, I'm nervous.
我说，我很紧张。
And she said, why?
她说，为什么？
And I said, I'm just nervous for people to know who I am.
我说，我只是担心人们知道我是谁。
And she said, I said, what's it going to be like?
她说，我说，那会是什么样子？
And she said, people are going to want pictures, and you'll get good tables at restaurants.
她说，人们会想要照片，而且你会在餐馆找到好桌子。
It's not that bad.
没那么糟糕。
It's fun.
很有趣。
That's really funny.
这真的很有趣。
And, you know, I found some stuff there.
而且，你知道，我在那里发现了一些东西。
Yeah.
是的。
Did leave out some stuff.
确实遗漏了一些东西。
But I definitely had this sense, like, like I said, I got fired for my first pilot.
但我确实有这种感觉，就像我说的，我的第一个飞行员被解雇了。
The second one got canceled very quickly after a couple episodes.
第二集在几集后很快就被取消了。
The third one didn't get picked up by NBC.
第三个没有被 NBC 接收。
Like I'd had everything happen to me, but a hit show.
就像一切都发生在我身上一样，除了一场热门节目。
So I kind of felt like, I don't know why I felt this way, but I was like, well, the odds are that, and I had a good feeling about it.
所以我有点感觉，我不知道为什么我有这种感觉，但我想，嗯，可能性就是这样，而且我对此有一种很好的感觉。
Like I said, at the end of the pilot.
就像我说的，在试播集结束时。
So I knew something was good and cool about the show.
所以我知道这个节目有一些很好而且很酷的东西。
What was strange was we shot the pilot in March.
奇怪的是我们在三月份枪杀了飞行员。
Something like that.
类似的事情。
I think we shot the pilot in March and then you end up shooting this in July, August.
我想我们在三月拍摄了试播集，然后你最终在七月、八月拍摄了这个。
August, probably, yeah.
八月，可能吧，是的。
But it's really, it's a couple days later, but you've had a couple months in between.
但实际上，这是几天后的事，但中间已经有几个月了。
You had a couple months, you found out it's picked up in May and then you had you start shooting in maybe early August or something, whatever.
你花了几个月的时间，你发现它在五月开始拍摄，然后你可能在八月初或其他时间开始拍摄，等等。
Yeah.
是的。
So, you know, it was like kind of like, okay, we're back, isn't this cool?
所以，你知道，就像是，好吧，我们回来了，这不是很酷吗？
But I was talking to a friend of mine last night who has a really cool theater opportunity in New York and he said, I'm nervous about going on the dopamine roller coaster when it gets announced and everyone's out, you know, saying, this is so great and how exciting and I just want to stay balanced.
但昨晚我和我的一个朋友聊天，他在纽约有一个非常酷的戏剧机会，他说，当它宣布并且每个人都出去时，我对乘坐多巴胺过山车感到紧张，你知道，说，这太棒了，多么令人兴奋，我只是想保持平衡。
And I told him, I said, I've had a lot of cool things happen in my career.
我告诉他，我说，在我的职业生涯中发生了很多很酷的事情。
And I was so afraid of seeming arrogant or out of touch or cocky in front of my friends who weren't at working that I didn't allow myself to enjoy things.
我非常害怕在不工作的朋友面前显得傲慢、脱离现实或自大，所以我不允许自己享受事情。
And I think that I had this fear of enjoying it too much.
我认为我害怕过度享受它。
Like I was really treading very delicately.
就像我真的走得非常微妙一样。
Like it was almost like don't scare the beast of showbiz that will take it all away.
就像不要吓到演艺界的野兽一样，它会夺走一切。
You know, it give it then it take it away, right?
你知道，它给予它然后又拿走它，对吗？
So I was very like, I was tiptoeing into it.
所以我非常喜欢，我正在小心翼翼地投入其中。
Yeah.
是的。
That's how I'm on planes.
我在飞机上就是这样。
I'm like, if I'm too comfortable, it's the thing going down.
我想，如果我太舒服了，事情就会下降。
You're exactly keeping the plane.
你确实在保留飞机。
I need my anxiety case, keeping it afloat.
我需要我的焦虑症，让它维持下去。
I remember Josh being, God, I feel like I have so many questions off of what you just said, including like, when did you start letting yourself believe this was going to go a minute, which is a good, I don't know what my answer is to either of us, I think.
我记得乔什说，上帝，我觉得我对你刚才所说的话有很多疑问，包括你什么时候开始让自己相信这会持续一分钟，这是一件好事，我想我不知道我对我们俩的答案是什么。
Yeah.
是的。
I know it took a while.
我知道这花了一段时间。
I remember being nervous because I really experienced some nerves, re-watching purple giraffe, a ton of delight too, but I remember the anxiety.
我记得很紧张，因为我真的经历了一些紧张，重新观看紫色长颈鹿，也很高兴，但我记得焦虑。
One of the anxieties was, I hope Josh on the cast like this script, they all signed up to do this pilot.
其中一个焦虑是，我希望演员阵容中的乔什喜欢这个剧本，他们都报名参加了这个试播集。
They all signed the years of their lives away to us based on this pilot.
根据这个试播集，他们都把自己生命中的岁月签给了我们。
It got picked up in May.
五月份就被捡到了。
You guys go have a summer while we're writing, writing, writing, trying to create, you know, get ahead of the beast.
你们去度过一个夏天，而我们正在写作，写作，写作，努力创造，你知道，超越野兽。
There's this giant pack man that's going to start eating up episodes two, three, four, five, You need to just start making episodes, like you've never made episodes before.
有一个巨大的包人将开始吃掉第二、三、四、五集，你需要开始制作剧集，就像你以前从未制作过剧集一样。
And I remember right, that's going to be the first one everybody is going to read all the people that believed in us, all the people at the studio, all the people in the network.
我没记错，这将是第一个让所有相信我们的人、工作室里的所有人、网络中的所有人阅读的书。
But most importantly, the cast and you, like, you and I always had a great bond and I knew you're a writer and like, I remember being nervous for you to read this motherfucker.
但最重要的是，演员们和你，就像，你和我一直有着很好的联系，我知道你是一个作家，我记得我对你读这个混蛋感到紧张。
I remember like, I hope he likes this script.
我记得，我希望他喜欢这个剧本。
Well, I will say I have a very strong memory of loving the script and I think I said this in the last episode, but I was delighted that the DNA of the pilot seemed to be very much baked into the second episode.
好吧，我会说我对喜欢这个剧本有一个非常强烈的记忆，我想我在上一集中说过这一点，但我很高兴飞行员的 DNA 似乎被融入到了第二集中。
And I was like, oh, I'm actually on a cool, I'm actually on pulp fiction meets, say anything or whatever, how we were describing it.
我当时想，哦，我实际上正在参加一个很酷的活动，我实际上正在参加低俗小说聚会，说任何话或其他什么，我们是如何描述它的。
Like there was something of a relief, not that just that it was funny, but that the playful, inventive storytelling was still present.
就像有一种松了一口气的感觉，不仅仅是因为它很有趣，而是因为有趣、有创意的故事讲述仍然存在。
Yeah, I just, I just really want to rest of our dogs where Tarantino will be all over this podcast because he apparently loves how much a mother and we're such enormous fans.
是的，我只是，我真的想让我们的狗休息一下，塔伦蒂诺将出现在这个播客中，因为他显然非常喜欢母亲，而我们是如此巨大的粉丝。
Another great fan came up to me.
另一位伟大的粉丝向我走来。
I think I told you came up to me at an event and it was just one of the ultimate honors.
我想我告诉过你在一次活动中找到我，这只是终极荣誉之一。
He's amazing.
他太棒了。
And such a huge influence on how much mother his work.
而母亲对他的工作影响有多大。
I rewatched.
我又看了一遍
I had COVID and I rewatched a lot of Tarantino and rewatching reservoir dogs.
我得了新冠肺炎，所以我重看了很多塔伦蒂诺的电影和水库狗。
There's that been in reservoir dogs where the undercover cop spoilers about reservoir dogs, the undercover cop Tim Roth who you don't know for a lot of the movie is that sorry if I just ruined the movie.
在《水库狗》中，卧底警察剧透了水库狗的故事，卧底警察蒂姆·罗斯（Tim Roth）你在电影中大部分时间都不认识，如果我毁了这部电影，我很抱歉。
You're seeing him learn his story that he's going to tell the other criminals as he's trying to infiltrate the group of criminals where he's memorizing and he starts off with just being handed like sides, like in auditions, like a scene.
你会看到他了解到他的故事，他打算告诉其他罪犯，因为他试图渗透到他正在记忆的犯罪集团中，而他一开始就像在试镜中一样，就像一个场景一样。
He's handed a scene by his mentor Cobb saying, learn this monologue.
他的导师科布给了他一个场景，告诉他“学习这段独白”。
It's a story about a job that went wrong or it's a story that it's called the Commode story.
这是一个关于工作出错的故事，或者是一个被称为“马桶故事”的故事。
It's the stressful moment where he has all these drugs in a bag and he walks in and there's cops in the bathroom And you see him learning and memorizing the story.
这是一个充满压力的时刻，他把所有这些毒品装在袋子里，他走进去，浴室里有警察，你看到他学习并记住了这个故事。
And watching Purple Giraffe, where Ted is planning out how his story's gonna go, how the party's gonna go, and you're jumping in and around, you're breaking the fourth wall, we're playing with it.
看《紫色长颈鹿》，泰德正在计划他的故事将如何进行，派对将如何进行，而你跳来跳去，你打破了第四堵墙，我们正在玩它。
It reminded me a lot of that.
这让我想起了很多。
And I was like, boy, reservoir dogs.
我就像，男孩，水库狗。
It was really, I think that was as much of Tarantino's films.
我认为塔伦蒂诺的电影确实如此。
That was a big influence, I think, on how much from other, just because it hit us at such a good moment.
我认为，这对其他人的影响很大，因为它在如此好的时刻击中了我们。
I know Carter.
我认识卡特。
It's fun when you're a writer, you don't even know what influence is you're pulling from.
当你是一名作家时，这很有趣，你甚至不知道自己受到了什么影响。
You just, it's all in there.
你只是，一切都在那里。
and you're kind of.
你是这样的。
Yeah.
是的。
There's, it's, I forgot about the Gatsby thing.
是的，是的，我忘了盖茨比的事了。
And Marshall at one point says, Hey, Gatsby, like, he, he addresses Ted that way, like at party two or three, as it's getting maniacal all these parties, he said something like, so Gatsby, what are you going to do?
马歇尔有一次说，嘿，盖茨比，就像，他，他这样称呼泰德，就像在第二次或第三次聚会上，因为所有这些聚会都变得疯狂，他说了这样的话，那么盖茨比，你要做什么？
And I was like, right, we threw that in.
我当时想，对吧，我们把它放进去了。
There was a nod to the fact that like, no one probably knew why the fuck he was calling him Gatsby.
人们承认这样一个事实：可能没有人知道他为什么他妈的叫他盖茨比。
Or you have to really like great Gatsby to make that particular parallel.
或者你必须非常喜欢伟大的盖茨比才能做出这种特殊的类比。
This is something I did want to say about this episode, but when Marshall holds up his law book, and he's like, has anyone seen, what is it?
关于这一集，这是我确实想说的，但是当马歇尔举起他的法律书时，他说，有人看到了吗，那是什么？
Like, Torrent Law, Constitutional, whatever, in the years.
就像这些年来的《洪流法》、《宪法》等等。
23, yeah.
23，是的。
Yeah.
是的。
I love that you say the whole name and it's like he's a good student or he wants to be.
我喜欢你说出整个名字，就好像他是一个好学生或者他想成为一个好学生。
He's trying to get through law school and it reminded me of something I just really liked about the show.
他正在努力完成法学院的学业，这让我想起了我非常喜欢这个节目的一些事情。
It's like a lot of shows were trying to be cool and have cool characters and then you had Big Bang, which wasn't on yet, but it was about to be that was just all about nerd culture and really went deep into the heart of that.
就像很多节目都试图变得很酷，拥有很酷的角色，然后就有了《生活大爆炸》，虽然还没有播出，但它即将成为关于书呆子文化的全部内容，并且真正深入到了它的核心。
How are my mother was like a cool show that was also nerdy in its own way?
我的母亲怎么像一部很酷的节目，但也有自己的书呆子风格？
Like it allowed for, it was almost like at my school, it was not socially a problem to be like both a valedictorian and super popular or like you could be in honors classes and also be, it wasn't frowned upon.
就像它所允许的那样，这几乎就像在我的学校一样，既像告别演说者又超级受欢迎，或者像你可以在荣誉班上一样，这在社会上并不是一个问题，这并不令人皱眉。
It was like, I kinda feel like how are my mother is like, It was both popular and it was also like a nerdy valedictorian at the same time, not that all the historians are nerdy, forgive me out there listening, but I love that it wore both its heart and its brain on its sleeve on some level.
就像，我有点觉得我的母亲是什么样的，它既受欢迎，同时也像一个书呆子的告别演说者，并不是所有的历史学家都是书呆子，请原谅我在外面听，但我喜欢它在某种程度上把它的心和大脑都暴露在袖子上。
Yeah, I did.
是的，我做到了。
I love that Marshall was trying to be a really good lost student and his big problem was that the leaders wanted to have sex on them all the time.
我喜欢马歇尔试图成为一个真正优秀的迷失学生，他的大问题是领导们总是想和他们发生性关系。
I was like, this is his problem in this episode.
我当时想，这是他在这一集中的问题。
But it's such a simple like like B story.
但这只是一个简单的B故事。
It's such a simple B story and it pays itself off when you kind of Gips up on the whole thing after he ruins it for time.
这是一个如此简单的B故事，当你在他毁掉了一段时间后你对整个事情感到惊讶时，它就会得到回报。
You just like, let's just go up sex.
你只是喜欢，让我们继续做爱吧。
And then let's get drunk.
然后我们就喝醉吧。
Let's get drunk at the end.
最后让我们一起醉吧。
He's still got a B minus.
他的成绩仍然是B-。
I love Saga.
我爱佐贺。
I love future Ted Poppin in there.
我喜欢那里未来的泰德波平。
Like he's still got a B minus.
好像他的成绩还是B减。
He Really was quite good considering he didn't really work.
考虑到他并没有真正工作，他真的很不错。
Greg, you and I have shared a lot of comedy loves and influences.
格雷格，你和我都有很多共同的喜剧爱好和影响。
I know Mati Python is definitely one of them.
我知道 Mati Python 绝对是其中之一。
We've talked about it a lot.
我们已经谈了很多了。
And the idea of very intelligent silliness.
以及非常聪明愚蠢的想法。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
I think it's crucially important to you, to your, to your writing, to your view of comedy.
我认为这对你、你的写作、你对喜剧的看法都至关重要。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
I mean, an incredible amount of intelligent effort put into something incredibly stupid is my favorite comment.
我的意思是，我最喜欢的评论是，在极其愚蠢的事情上投入了令人难以置信的智慧努力。
That's my favorite version.
这是我最喜欢的版本。
That's one of my favorite things in the world.
这是世界上我最喜欢的事情之一。
And that's, and that sort of speaks to Ted a little bit in this episode, because he's constructing something completely stupid.
这就是，这在这一集中对泰德有一点启发，因为他正在构建一些完全愚蠢的东西。
He throws three parties in a row.
他连续举办了三个聚会。
It's so clear to even ramen it by by the end, I was like, ramen must know, but he's, but you get it's this glimpse under the hood for Ted.
到最后，甚至拉面都已经很清楚了，我想，拉面必须知道，但他是，但你知道这是泰德的一瞥。
That's the other thing I really liked about the episode.
这是我真正喜欢这一集的另一件事。
We got to know Barney a little more.
我们对巴尼有了更多的了解。
We got to know Marshall Lillie.
我们认识了马歇尔·莉莉。
I loved the boundaries, Joe, commercial Lillie, you're having this very sexual talk and you come on.
我喜欢界限，乔，商业广告莉莉，你正在谈论这个非常性感的谈话，你来吧。
That's his guys boundaries.
那是他的人的界限。
It comes back.
它回来了。
It comes back really nicely in the college flashback.
它在大学闪回中非常好地回归。
I don't know when that was, but that guy.
我不知道那是什么时候，但就是那个人。
Oh yeah, totally.
哦，是的，完全可以。
And it plays off the bunk bed joke in the pilot.
它与试播集中的双层床笑话相呼应。
And it's just like, it's so great.
就好像，这太棒了。
It just defines that that trifecta's dynamic, it's also a great two-word joke, which is hard to do.
它只是定义了三连胜的动态，这也是一个很棒的两个字笑话，这很难做到。
Guys, boundaries.
伙计们，边界。
I know like deep thoughts, Jack Handy was like, he was always trying to make the fewest words to be the punch line.
我知道杰克·汉迪就像深思熟虑一样，他总是试图用最少的词语来成为笑点。
And I was like, ah, two-word joke.
我当时就想，啊，两个字的笑话。
That's good.
那挺好的。
But I just found that like more than anything purple giraffe is like getting deeper into Ted's.
但我刚刚发现紫色长颈鹿比任何东西都更喜欢深入泰德的内心。
Like the great things about Ted and the insanity about Ted.
就像泰德的伟大之处和泰德的疯狂一样。
the idea that he can plan all of this, but that he's this unbelievably boundless optimist.
他可以计划这一切，但他是一个令人难以置信的无限乐观主义者。
There's an early moment where they're trying to mature, but I think Robin's silence of not having called and Ted says something like, I'm going to spin this as good.
他们在早期阶段正试图成熟，但我认为罗宾没有打电话而保持沉默，泰德说了类似的话，我会把这件事说得很好。
And he has no reason to be spinning it as good.
他没有理由把它说得那么好。
And there's no, it's neutral or bad.
没有，它是中性的或坏的。
It's not good.
这不好。
But he hasn't called it.
但他还没有叫过。
Whatever he's talking about is literally, they're not good.
无论他在说什么，从字面上看，他们都不好。
And I just loved him so much at that moment because he's, that might as well be his mission to, I'm going to spin this as good.
那一刻我非常爱他，因为他，这也可能是他的使命，我要把这件事转好。
The whole story, future Ted is telling his kids this story and spinning it as mostly good even the hard parts.
整个故事，未来的泰德正在向他的孩子们讲述这个故事，并将其编成大部分都很好，甚至包括困难的部分。
Like the whole, it felt like the motto of the whole series in some ways and there were a few of those in here.
就像整个系列一样，它在某种程度上感觉像是整个系列的座右铭，这里也有一些这样的座右铭。
Did you find, I found very, I really loved Ted in this episode, started to finish and the moment where Ted is so generous, he could have said goodbye to Robin forever up on that roof.
你有没有发现，我发现我非常非常喜欢这一集中的泰德，从开始到结束，当泰德如此慷慨的那一刻，他本可以在屋顶上永远告别罗宾。
The first rooftop scene, that was how I met the roof.
第一个屋顶场景，我就是这样认识屋顶的。
The first Ted Robin rooftop scene, rooftop kiss, all that was like, oh my God, right, that's all in here.
泰德罗宾的第一个屋顶场景，屋顶之吻，所有这些就像，天哪，对了，都在这里。
And then he can just let her go forever and be and hide from this embarrassing experience, but instead because he's such a good guy, he says, or you know, tonight, we can hang out tonight.
然后他就可以让她永远离开，躲开这段尴尬的经历，但相反，因为他是个好人，他说，或者你知道，今晚我们可以一起出去玩。
And she sees that she's vulnerable and alone.
她发现自己很脆弱且孤独。
And that's how she's brought into the group through this magnanimous act from Ted.
这就是她如何通过特德的慷慨行为被带入这个团体的。
I just loved Ted so much in that moment.
那一刻我非常爱特德。
I think it's a great Ted episode, this whole one.
我认为这是一部很棒的泰德剧集，整部剧。
How did it feel already watching it to you, sort of Karen?
凯伦，你看完这部电影感觉如何？
Like I think about that whole story.
就像我思考整个故事一样。
The Ted Ted was, Ted is carrying that episode in a great way.
泰德 泰德是，泰德以一种很好的方式演绎了这一集。
Yeah, definitely.
是的，绝对是。
I remember feeling the kind of weight of it on my shoulders, like, you know what, I have, there's certain sensory or like somatic memories that I have.
我记得感觉到它在我肩上的重量，就像，你知道吗，我有，我有某些感觉或类似的躯体记忆。
I remember, and it made me laugh when I watched it, but when he's running to get to the convenience martyr or whatever, where Robin is reporting on the kid's stock, and he runs into frame on TV.
我记得，当我看到它时，我笑了，但是当他跑去方便烈士或其他地方时，罗宾正在报道孩子的股票，他遇到了电视上的画面。
That's not that many laugh out loud.
笑起来的人并不多。
Yeah, it's so funny, but I remember for the second time in the episode, it breaks the first hole.
是的，这太有趣了，但我记得在这一集中第二次，它打破了第一个洞。
It looks right into the camera and that earlier joke yet, it was great.
它直视镜头，还有之前的笑话，太棒了。
But I remember, you know, you, I remember them sweating you up, you know, they're just misting you.
但我记得，你知道，你，我记得他们让你出汗，你知道，他们只是让你迷失。
And then I really like when the little kid says, you're sweaty, sweaty, tries to talk to the little kid.
然后我真的很喜欢那个小孩说，你满身大汗，满身大汗，试着和那个小孩说话。
That was really funny.
那真的很有趣。
Yeah.
是的。
And how the little kid also see, like, I'm very claustrophobic, I would not do well in that booth, but the little kid seemed totally fine, which for some reason made me laugh.
那个小孩也看到了，比如，我有幽闭恐惧症，我在那个摊位上表现不好，但那个小孩看起来完全没问题，这出于某种原因让我笑了。
like he didn't seem put out by being there.
好像他并没有因为在那里而感到沮丧。
He's very chill.
他很冷淡。
But I remember that scene very well with Kobe for some reason, shooting that scene.
但出于某种原因，我对科比的那个场景记得很清楚，拍摄那个场景。
And just like running, Ted had to do a lot of running.
就像跑步一样，特德也必须进行大量的跑步。
You know on the New York street, like he threw out the nine years.
你知道在纽约街头，就像他扔掉了九年一样。
I remember running.
我记得跑步。
I remember, and at some point, maybe it was because I was getting older, I was like, oh yeah, you should stretch, stretch before this.
我记得，在某些时候，也许是因为我变老了，我想，哦，是的，在这之前你应该伸展，伸展。
You're gonna wake up, sorry, if you just like bust into like a sprint five times in a row.
对不起，如果你只是喜欢连续五次冲刺的话，你就会醒来。
But yeah, I mean, I'm having an experience of, because I remember this is like quite vulnerable to share, but I've actually talked about this before.
但是，是的，我的意思是，我有过这样的经历，因为我记得这很容易分享，但我之前实际上已经讨论过这一点。
So I learned very quickly, like, don't go on the internet and read comments, right?
所以我很快就学会了，比如，不要上网看评论，对吧？
But I remember after Purple Draft came on and this is where I gave myself this rule because I saw people are saying really nice things about the show and about me and oh isn't this delightful.
但我记得《紫色选秀》播出后，我给自己制定了这条规则，因为我看到人们对这部剧和我都说很多好话，哦，这不是很令人愉快吗？
And then Jason used to say that he goes, he said, I don't read because you have to admit at some point you're actually looking for the mean thing.
然后杰森常说他去，他说，我不读书，因为你必须承认在某些时候你实际上是在寻找卑鄙的东西。
You're looking for the mean thing and it's horrible to do to yourself, right?
你正在寻找卑鄙的事情，而对自己做的事情很可怕，对吧？
But I remember seeing some comments where people said, I like the pilot, but what is this guy just a stalker now?
但我记得看到一些评论，人们说，我喜欢飞行员，但这家伙现在只是跟踪狂吗？
Is he just going to like keep stalking this woman?
他就这么想继续跟踪这个女人吗？
And they were really kind of tough on him.
他们对他真的很严厉。
Where I thought it was like, no, he's like, I almost felt like they didn't understand the essential goofy charm of the guy.
我以为，不，他就像，我几乎觉得他们不理解这个家伙本质上的愚蠢魅力。
They wanted him to be, you know, everyone has opinions.
他们希望他成为，你知道，每个人都有意见。
But then someone said, this was the favorite thing I've ever read about myself online.
但后来有人说，这是我在网上读过的关于自己的最喜欢的事情。
Someone said, I'm trying to figure out what it is I don't like about this guy, meaning me.
有人说，我想弄清楚我不喜欢这个人的什么地方，指的是我。
I think I finally figured it out.
我想我终于明白了。
His face.
他的脸。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
So then you go back to work and you're like, well, you think that eight million people just said that instead of one guy who instead of, you know, your dad, yeah, that was a real as I'll comment if I have.
然后你回去工作，你会想，好吧，你认为八百万人刚刚说了这句话，而不是一个人，而不是你的父亲，是的，这是真实的，如果我有的话，我会发表评论。
Yeah.
是的。
Right.
正确的。
You hear that as if it's everybody saying.
你听到的好像每个人都这么说。
You hear it as if it's everybody.
你听着就好像每个人都这样。
And so I'm watching the show with a 20 year kind of, I feel like I'm having this experience of being kinder to the younger me who, I mean, it is so much like older Ted looking back on younger Ted.
所以我以 20 岁的年龄观看这部剧，我觉得我正在经历对年轻的我更加友善的经历，我的意思是，这很像年长的泰德回顾年轻的泰德。
Older Ted has so much more grace and perspective than younger Ted does.
年长的泰德比年轻的泰德有更多的优雅和远见。
So I watched this episode and I watched it with Jordana and I just was like, this show is really funny and sweet and smart and I was good.
所以我看了这一集，我和乔丹娜一起看了，我就想，这个节目真的很有趣、甜蜜、聪明，我很好。
I was good at this and it's been very healing for me.
我很擅长这个，这对我来说非常治愈。
Not that I didn't think I was, I had some sense that I was doing the job that I was asked to do.
并不是说我不这么认为，我有一种感觉，我正在做我被要求做的工作。
And I was doing it as well as I could, I knew how to do.
我已经尽力了，我知道该怎么做。
But I actually found myself liking Ted a lot more than I thought I would.
但我实际上发现自己比我想象的更喜欢特德。
I don't, maybe, maybe he becomes more annoying or something, but I found myself being like, nah, I like this guy.
我不，也许，也许他变得更烦人什么的，但我发现自己就像，不，我喜欢这个家伙。
I'm on his side.
我站在他一边。
I want him to get the girl.
我想让他得到那个女孩。
I want him to have the life of his dreams.
我希望他能过上他梦想的生活。
I was very, um, again, you do a little mini fake out where you have, again, like, that, and I, and I also was like, Kobe and I had really good chemistry.
我非常，嗯，再一次，你做了一个小小的假动作，你再次，就像那样，我，我也说，科比和我有很好的化学反应。
I was really delighted by that like very much so the you know when he says I can turn it off I can turn it off I can I it doesn't it's turned off doesn't he like click his heart or something he Turns it off before he kisses her and it's just like you feel that there's like real heat And she's attracted to him and this this and then he's like I can't I can't do it.
我真的很高兴，所以你知道，当他说我可以把它关掉时，我可以把它关掉，我可以，但它不关掉，他不喜欢敲击他的心或其他东西吗？他在亲吻她之前把它关掉，就像你感觉到有真正的热量，她被他吸引了，这个，然后他就像我不能，我不能这样做。
I can't turn it off And this old man He must did me fell in love with you New York City And now, commercials.
我无法将其关闭 而这个老人 他一定让我爱上了你 纽约 现在，广告。
Alec, you know what happened to me when I found a good therapist?
亚历克，你知道当我找到一位好的治疗师后我发生了什么吗？
What happened to you when you found a good therapist?
当你找到一位好的治疗师后，你发生了什么？
I married her.
我娶了她。
Oh!
哦！
My wife Jordana is a therapist, a wonderful therapist, but today we're talking about Rula, which I believe Alec, you have used and can tell us a little more about.
我的妻子乔丹娜是一位治疗师，一位出色的治疗师，但今天我们谈论的是鲁拉，我相信亚历克，你已经使用过它并且可以告诉我们更多关于它的信息。
I can and I would like to announce first that I did not marry a single one of the therapists that I have used.
我可以而且我想首先宣布，我没有与我所使用的治疗师中的任何一位结婚。
It's good to say that right up front.
最好提前说清楚。
disclaimer.
免责声明。
Yes, no rule is it's it's fantastic.
是的，没有规则，它太棒了。
It's a it's a way of finding an online therapist and I have used them for years.
这是寻找在线治疗师的一种方式，我已经使用它们很多年了。
It's basically built the way you would want a kind of website like this to be built.
它基本上是按照您想要的类似网站的方式构建的。
You go on and you get to tell a little bit about what what you're looking for and you get a list of therapists and they could be anywhere because this is entirely online.
你继续下去，你可以告诉你一些你在寻找什么，你会得到一份治疗师名单，他们可能在任何地方，因为这完全是在线的。
So you have a very large list and they'll tell you about themselves.
所以你有一个非常大的名单，他们会告诉你他们自己。
They have great bios of what what brought them to this work, what interests them, what kind of work they've done in the past, what their techniques are, and you get to get a sense of who they are, which is completely different from, we just walk into a therapist's office.
他们有很好的简历，告诉他们是什么让他们从事这项工作，他们对什么感兴趣，他们过去做过什么样的工作，他们的技术是什么，你可以了解他们是谁，这与我们走进治疗师的办公室完全不同。
You're just meeting this person for the first time, and what's really great about it is you can change, and you could change because the fit isn't quite right, or actually just recently I changed because it had been a long time with one therapist and I just sort of had a sense that it was time to change, and really makes it so easy, you just go, you have your list of therapists, then you can just choose whoever you feel is the right fit for you.
你只是第一次见到这个人，真正伟大的是你可以改变，你可以改变，因为不合适，或者实际上最近我才改变，因为与一位治疗师相处了很长时间，我只是有一种感觉，是时候改变了，而且真的让这变得如此简单，你只要走，你有你的治疗师名单，然后你可以选择任何你认为最适合你的人。
It almost sounds like Rula, and I hope they're okay with me saying this.
这听起来几乎像鲁拉，我希望他们同意我这么说。
It's like a Somalia for therapists.
这就像治疗师的索马里。
It is, it's exactly what it is.
是的，就是这样。
You've got to start what you're looking for and they say, I have a lovely, I have a lovely person in Denver, Colorado for you.
你必须开始寻找你正在寻找的东西，他们说，我在科罗拉多州丹佛市有一个可爱的人在找你。
That's right, and they give you just a little bit and you just take a little sip for at first.
没错，他们只给你一点点，你一开始只喝一小口。
You just have your one appointment, see if it fits and if not, you send it back and you get that next bottle.
您只需进行一次预约，看看它是否合适，如果不合适，您将其寄回并获得下一瓶。
And I can attest as Alex's longtime friend.
作为亚历克斯的老朋友，我可以作证。
He used to be, uh, he needs to be a mess.
他曾经是，呃，他需要变得一团糟。
And now he's all, he's doing great.
现在他一切都好了，他做得很好。
You knew me in the pre-Rula days.
你在鲁拉时代之前就认识我了。
Those were dark days.
那是一段黑暗的日子。
I didn't, I don't wish you pre-rule on anyone.
我没有，我不希望你对任何人做出预先裁决。
But they've done great work with you.
但他们和你一起做了很棒的工作。
You're, you're a shining example of what can happen.
你是，你是可能发生的事情的光辉榜样。
Rula helps you find licensed therapists and psychiatrists who truly align with your background in goals rather than just assigning you the first open slot available.
Rula 帮助您找到真正符合您目标背景的有执照的治疗师和精神科医生，而不是仅仅为您分配第一个可用的空缺职位。
Even better, RULA RULA RULA works with over 100 major insurance plans nationwide, bringing the average session copay to just $15.
更好的是，RULA RULA RULA 与全国 100 多个主要保险计划合作，使平均疗程自付额仅为 15 美元。
They support you from day one, tracking your milestones and helping you monitor your care along the way to ensure you are actually moving forward.
他们从第一天起就为您提供支持，跟踪您的里程碑并帮助您全程监控您的护理，以确保您真正取得进展。
Thousands of people are already using RULA to get affordable high quality therapy that's actually covered by insurance.
成千上万的人已经在使用 RULA 来获得负担得起的高质量治疗，而且这些治疗实际上是由保险承保的。
Visit RULA.com slash your mother to get started.
访问 RULA.com 砍掉你的母亲即可开始。
It's RULA-R-U-L-A dot com slash your mother.
这是 RULA-R-U-L-A .com 砍你妈妈。
You deserve mental health care that works with you, not against your budget.
您应该得到适合您的心理健康护理，而不是违反您的预算。
As a young adult, finding the right path to your future can feel overwhelming.
作为一个年轻人，找到通往未来的正确道路可能会让人感到不知所措。
It starts with year-up unites tuition-free job training program career pathways.
它从一年级开始，统一了免学费的职业培训计划的职业道路。
If you're without a bachelor's degree, but have a high school diploma or GED, you can get skills first training to succeed in the industries you're passionate about, all while earning a weekly educational stipend to offset basic expenses.
如果您没有学士学位，但拥有高中文凭或 GED，您可以获得技能优先培训，以便在您热衷的行业中取得成功，同时每周赚取教育津贴来抵消基本费用。
From there, you'll have access to internships and hands-on experiences with Fortune 500 companies, and with year-up unites, job placement services, and personalized coaching and mentorship, you can put your knowledge, skills, and most importantly, confidence into practice.
从那里，您将有机会获得财富 500 强公司的实习机会和实践经验，并通过年升单位、就业安置服务以及个性化辅导和指导，您可以将您的知识、技能，最重要的是，信心付诸实践。
Apply to year-up united today and take the first step toward achieving the career you want.
立即申请year-up United，迈出实现您想要的职业生涯的第一步。
Visit yearup.org to learn more.
访问yearup.org 了解更多信息。
And of commercials back to show.
和广告回来展示。
There's so many things that I liked about Ted in that scene.
那个场景中有很多我喜欢特德的地方。
He confessed to the completely insane thing he had done.
他承认了自己所做的完全疯狂的事情。
She's somewhat charmed by it.
她有些着迷。
She also admits that she's into him, right?
她也承认自己喜欢他吧？
She says you're not imagining it.
她说你没有想象到。
You're not imagining it.
你没有想象到。
And then he plays that right.
然后他就发挥了正确的作用。
And they kiss.
他们接吻了。
And that was That was a sexy scene between you guys.
那就是你们之间的性感场景。
That was there was heat in that scene.
那个场景很热。
I really liked it.
我真的很喜欢它。
And I was like, that, I mean, you worry things won't carry over from the pilot.
我当时想，我的意思是，你担心事情不会从飞行员身上延续下来。
You had such chemistry in the pilot.
你们在试播集里就有了这样的化学反应。
Will we be able to preserve that?
我们能保留它吗？
I'm so too.
我也是这样啊
Big time.
很开心。
And I almost forgot how like, like intense that kiss, how good that kiss, that was a good rooftop kiss.
我几乎忘记了那个吻有多强烈，那个吻有多好，那是一个很棒的屋顶吻。
That was a magical New York city skyline behind you guys kiss.
你们亲吻背后那是神奇的纽约市天际线。
That was like, I almost forgot how great that was.
就像，我几乎忘记了那是多么伟大。
That was the big moment of the episode.
那是这一集的重要时刻。
It was almost like I forgot how big that important that moment was.
我几乎忘记了那一刻有多么重要。
And then Ted is then is self knowing enough to say there's not there's no off switch.
然后特德就足够了解自己了，他说不存在关闭开关。
I can't do it.
我做不到。
And then it's the easiest thing in the world for him to never see her again.
然后他再也见不到她了，这是世界上最容易的事情。
But he sees she's lonely and then he extends that imitation essentially come join the group.
但他看到她很孤独，然后他扩展了这种模仿本质上加入了这个群体。
And I just there's all of those moments there's so many moments in that whole sequence up on the roof.
我只是在屋顶上的整个序列中有很多时刻。
And so many things for Ted to play there.
特德可以在那里玩很多东西。
He's the hero.
他是英雄。
He's the fool.
他就是个傻瓜。
He's incredibly generous.
他非常慷慨。
it ends on this note.
就这样结束了。
Ted's the one who makes Robin be part of the group.
泰德是让罗宾成为团队一员的人。
That's why we have the TV show we have.
这就是我们拥有电视节目的原因。
That's why the team is the team.
这就是为什么团队就是团队。
He brought her in and I loved it.
他带她进来，我很喜欢。
I love it.
我喜欢它。
I think you really love Ted.
我想你真的很爱特德。
And about that stuff about like, is he a stalker or whatever?
关于诸如此类的事情，他是跟踪狂还是其他什么？
I would just say that what what great TV show has like normal well-balanced people making great decisions all the time.
我只想说，伟大的电视节目就像正常的平衡的人总是做出伟大的决定一样。
Where's the show?
演出在哪里？
I have this ongoing show like my dad that's been going on for decades.
像我父亲一样，我有一个正在进行的节目，已经持续了几十年。
It's my dad, he watches things through this incredibly moral lens.
这是我的父亲，他通过这种令人难以置信的道德镜头来看待事物。
So he watches things, he goes, why would these people screw up their lives so bad?
所以他观察事情，他说，为什么这些人会把他们的生活搞得这么糟糕？
And I'm like, Dad, so you can have something to watch.
我想，爸爸，所以你可以看点东西。
Right.
正确的。
There's no story.
没有故事。
Just nailing it all the time, just like making all the right decisions.
一直坚持下去，就像做出所有正确的决定一样。
That's not a good show.
这可不是什么好戏。
Shows are characters who have some sort of central defect of their character who have to kind of transcend and and and grow up and learn and go and move somewhere we need.
电视剧中的角色有某种核心缺陷，他们必须超越、成长、学习、去往我们需要的地方。
You actually have to start people kind of in a in somewhat of a tough place generally.
实际上，你通常必须在一个比较困难的地方开始人们的工作。
A couple of things that I'll just point out.
我只想指出一些事情。
We've answered some questions that we got by the way and I have some factoids for you.
顺便说一下，我们已经回答了一些问题，并且我有一些事实要告诉您。
But a lot of people asked about the roof whether or not it wasn't exterior, which I think goes to Chris Lafontaine and to the set designers and Steve Olsen.
但很多人问屋顶是否不是外部的，我认为这是克里斯·拉方丹、布景设计师和史蒂夫·奥尔森的问题。
Yeah, we had an amazing team.
是的，我们有一支很棒的团队。
It's not that is on a that is on a sounds stage, that's on stage 22 in West L.A.
这不是在音响舞台上，而是在西洛杉矶的 22 号舞台上。
and on the Fox Lod.
还有狐狸洛德。
And it looks great.
而且看起来很棒。
It looks like I love that people are fooled by that.
看起来我喜欢人们被它愚弄。
That's the Emmy winning combination of our cinematographer, Chris Luffantane and our set designer, Steve Olsen.
这是我们的电影摄影师 Chris Luffantane 和我们的布景设计师 Steve Olsen 的艾美奖获奖组合。
And also even little subtle things like they're always fans, but kind of from far away.
甚至还有一些微妙的事情，比如他们总是粉丝，但有点遥远。
So there'd be like the ever-so-slightest breeze moving through.
因此，就像有微风吹过一样。
As I was watching the credits, I was like, well, a lot of these people just stayed on the show, the entire time, which is I think pretty incredible.
当我观看片尾字幕时，我想，很多人一直都留在节目中，我认为这非常令人难以置信。
Josh was speaking to that earlier and just saying like the, it's all of these people deserve this credit for what the show continues to mean to people because it's so immersive.
乔什早些时候曾谈到这一点，只是说，所有这些人都应该得到这个荣誉，因为这部剧对人们来说仍然意味着什么，因为它是如此身临其境。
It's an immersive universe because everyone killed it, everyone had a lot of fun.
这是一个身临其境的宇宙，因为每个人都杀了它，每个人都玩得很开心。
Flannel Pajamra's would like us to know that the little boy in the claw machine, if you don't know, played SJ in the blind side.
Flannel Pajamra 希望我们知道夹娃娃机里的小男孩，如果你不知道的话，他在盲区扮演 SJ。
His name is J head went on to a couple of films.
他的名字叫J Head，拍过几部电影。
And I just wanted to say that I also love that it's funny that you were worried that it would feel like a contained party episode or I felt like what was great is it kind of went farce very quickly.
我只是想说，我也喜欢你担心这会感觉像是一场封闭的派对剧集，或者我觉得很棒的是它很快就变成了闹剧，这很有趣。
It felt very big to me, actually, that it, I mean, you have this feeling of you're wearing these wet socks, like something is definitely awful happening right here, right now you cannot quite get out of it.
事实上，这对我来说感觉非常大，我的意思是，你有一种感觉，你穿着这些湿袜子，就像这里肯定发生了一些可怕的事情，现在你无法完全摆脱它。
But you're stuck in this sort of hell of your own making.
但你却被困在自己一手造成的地狱里。
It's almost groundhog day, right?
快到土拨鼠日了，对吧？
It's like the same really.
真的就像是一样的。
What occurred to me was that you've replaced door slamming with editing, that the timing of this show, and it's the door slam.
我想到的是，你用剪辑代替了关门声，这个节目的时机，就是关门声。
Yeah, you have your editor who won several, several Emmy suit better, many one in several areas of this.
是的，你的编辑赢得了好几座艾美奖，更适合在这几个领域获得很多奖项。
But it's also in the writing that that bam, bam, bam, that this happens, bam, exactly at the right timing, felt like TV force, which is so rare and great to have on a, you know, I love that expression.
但在写作中，“砰”、“砰”、“砰”，这种情况发生了，“砰”，恰好在正确的时间，感觉就像电视力量，这是非常罕见和伟大的，你知道，我喜欢这种表达方式。
Edited is the door slam that we kind of did.
编辑的是我们所做的关门声。
That's what punches the joke a lot of time.
这就是很多时候笑话的原因。
And that's, we were really adamant, Cardinal, and I to make sure episode two still conveyed that.
也就是说，我们真的很坚定，红衣主教和我要确保第二集仍然传达这一点。
We're still going to be that show.
我们仍然会成为那个节目。
We are a show that is cinematic and we will edit it.
我们是一个电影化的节目，我们将对其进行剪辑。
And it will be, it will not lag.
确实如此，也不会滞后。
It will not be a big, long party scene that loses energy, it will be boom, boom, boom, still even though we had to sort of play some big party scenes along the way.
这不会是一个大而长的派对场景，失去能量，它会是繁荣、繁荣、繁荣，尽管我们不得不一路上播放一些大型派对场景。
But I think that's why it mattered so much to us to do that kind of cinematic montage at the end that equates Ted to the little boy climbing up, trying to grab the prize, trying to escape the system, and skip the necessary steps and jump ahead and grab the prize.
但我认为这就是为什么对我们来说如此重要的是在最后制作那种电影蒙太奇，将泰德等同于小男孩爬上去，试图抓住奖品，试图逃离系统，跳过必要的步骤，向前跳跃并抓住奖品。
And he ends up getting stuck in there.
他最终被困在那里。
And there's obviously a very nice metaphor there for what Ted's trying to do and speaking to some of Ted's own flaws of thinking he can plan everything and skip ahead.
显然，对于泰德想要做的事情，有一个非常好的隐喻，并谈到了泰德自己的一些缺陷，即认为他可以计划一切并跳过。
And, you know, the whole, I liked when Ted says this line in that sort of like, I can still win this.
而且，你知道，总的来说，我喜欢特德以那种类似的方式说这句话，我仍然可以赢得这场比赛。
And that metaphor of the game, it's a game I can win.
游戏的比喻是，这是一场我能赢的游戏。
It's a blueprint.
这是一个蓝图。
I can draw it's a plan.
我可以画出它是一个计划。
I can achieve it perfectly.
我可以完美地实现它。
And that is Ted's flaw.
这就是特德的缺点。
He has to let go of some of it.
他必须放弃一些。
In some ways, Ted is like, Horatio Alger.
在某些方面，特德就像霍雷肖·阿尔杰。
He's like the American dream.
他就像美国梦。
He's like, he's really bought into this idea that with effort and with vision, I can do anything.
他就像，他真的相信这样一个想法：只要努力和有远见，我可以做任何事。
And I think that that's lovable.
我认为这很可爱。
But it's also, it's not at least at the beginning of this series.
但至少在本系列的开始部分并非如此。
It's not tempered by realism, by patience, by like what the show and what the universe and what these experiences teach him is, you know, you can only plan so much.
它不受现实主义、耐心、像节目、宇宙和这些经历教给他的东西的影响，你知道，你只能计划这么多。
Like we, like it's a perfect job for him.
就像我们一样，这对他来说是一份完美的工作。
He's an architect.
他是一名建筑师。
He's trying to construct and build this life for himself.
他正在努力为自己构建和建造这种生活。
And the universe keeps like, you know, blowing away the blueprint and putting it in a puddle of water.
你知道，宇宙一直在吹走蓝图并将其放入一洼水中。
It's like, he's not going to be able to, he has to, I mean, it's like, I don't know, Star Wars, but like he has to like take off the thing and like guide like Star Wars, right?
就像，他不能，他必须，我的意思是，这就像，我不知道，星球大战，但就像他必须喜欢脱掉东西并喜欢像星球大战那样的指南，对吧？
Like where he has to take off the vision thing and he has to do it blind and just feel it.
就像他必须去掉视觉的东西，他必须盲目地去做，只是感觉它。
I think that thing versions of that happened about eight times in Star Wars movie.
我认为类似的事情在《星球大战》电影中发生了大约八次。
Star Wars.
星球大战。
Yeah.
是的。
Star Wars.
星球大战。
He has to take off his mark in the computer.
他必须去掉电脑上的标记。
Thank you.
谢谢。
I don't really know it that well.
我真的不太了解。
I'm not a Star Wars person.
我不是星球大战的人。
That's why I was tentative about.
这就是我试探性的原因。
I love how you're really trying to pretend.
我喜欢你努力假装的样子。
You don't watch that movie every day.
你不是每天都看那部电影。
It's not working.
它不起作用。
That's what people think.
人们就是这么想的。
No, we're trying to dispel this idea that he's not what I was watching Star Wars car.
不，我们正在努力消除这种想法，即他不是我正在观看的星球大战汽车。
Well, maybe I should stop citing it.
好吧，也许我应该停止引用它。
And you're bringing this on yourself.
而这一切都是你自找的。
You know, I mean, it is a little bit like Groundhog because Ted is trying to construct fate and destiny here over and over again in this episode.
你知道，我的意思是，这有点像土拨鼠，因为泰德在这一集中试图一次又一次地构建命运和命运。
He's trying to manufacture things that maybe are supposed to happen more organically.
他正在尝试制造一些本来应该更有机地发生的事情。
He's running into live shots of the news.
他正在看到新闻的现场镜头。
He's doing not one party, not two parties, but three parties and pretending that was the plan, the whole time, he's sort of trying to fake out that's to mean it and cheat that's to mean it.
他参加的不是一场派对，也不是两场派对，而是三场派对，并假装这就是他的计划，自始至终，他都在试图假装那是真心话，欺骗那是真心话。
Just like that little kid was trying to steal the purple giraffe by the way, cameo alert.
就像那个小孩子想顺便偷走紫色长颈鹿一样，客串警报。
And I know this is a not a visual medium for most people, but purple giraffe.
我知道这对大多数人来说不是视觉媒介，而是紫色长颈鹿。
That's the actual key to purple giraffe.
这才是紫色长颈鹿的真正关键。
This is the purple giraffe.
这是紫色的长颈鹿。
Named so and this item is what it is because my wife's favorite color is purple.
之所以如此命名，是因为我妻子最喜欢的颜色是紫色。
And her favorite animal is a giraffe and the purple giraffe lives in our home to this day?
她最喜欢的动物是长颈鹿，紫色长颈鹿至今还住在我们家？
It's not amazing that you and Carter could just be like, it'll be a purple giraffe and then they just present you with a purple giraffe.
你和卡特可能会说，这将是一只紫色长颈鹿，然后他们就向你呈现一只紫色长颈鹿，这并不奇怪。
Like you just manifest these things out of your imagination and then they make it real.
就像你只是将这些东西从你的想象中显现出来，然后它们就会使它成为现实。
Yeah, and props had to make that and it was a pain in the ass.
是的，道具必须做到这一点，这真是一件痛苦的事。
I remember like the day from props coming around, like is this okay?
我记得就像道具出现的那一天，这样可以吗？
And it was like having to cobble it together.
这就像必须将它们拼凑在一起。
There wasn't just a purple giraffe to buy.
不仅有一只紫色长颈鹿可供购买。
He had to like make this.
他必须喜欢做这个。
Right, right.
对，对。
I love this idea that Ted is, he's both a believer in destiny, but he also disbelieves it.
我喜欢特德的这个想法，他既相信命运，但又不相信命运。
he doesn't believe that it'll just not be like, he has to engineer it, he has to get in there in metal.
他不相信这不会是这样，他必须设计它，他必须用金属进入那里。
He has to architect it.
他必须设计它。
And I love when he said that.
我喜欢他这么说。
Yeah, one of my favorites, but he really wants to be the beneficiary of the blessing of the universe.
是的，我最喜欢的人之一，但他真的很想成为宇宙祝福的受益者。
Yeah, but he refuses to allow the universe to do its job.
是的，但他拒绝让宇宙发挥其作用。
Yeah, that's such a great way to put it down.
是的，这是一个很好的放下它的方式。
He wants to climb up into that toy machine and get the toy he wants and he gets stuck.
他想爬进玩具机器并得到他想要的玩具，但他被卡住了。
He gets stuck.
他被卡住了。
not how it works.
不是它是如何工作的。
And so I think part of why we want to do that big cinematic montage of sort of Ted and end of the kid and the attempt to the claw reaching for this thing that it shouldn't, you know, it can't quite grasp.
所以我想部分原因是我们想要制作泰德和孩子的结局那样的大电影蒙太奇，以及试图用爪子伸向这个不应该的东西，你知道，它无法完全抓住。
That was us wanting to say, this is not just our party episode, it's a wacky party.
我们想说的是，这不仅仅是我们的派对插曲，这是一个古怪的派对。
It's like this episode's about something too.
好像这一集也讲了一些事情。
And it's about something that Ted, we will watch this series.
这是关于特德的事情，我们将观看这个系列。
I feel like that episode gave you a whole bunch of threads to track through the rest of the series, one of them being Ted's tug of war between do you let something just happen or do you architect it into happening?
我觉得那一集给了你一大堆线索来追踪该系列的其余部分，其中之一是泰德的拉锯战，你是让事情自然发生还是你策划它发生？
And it is one of the central big debates.
这是主要争论之一。
And with the second episode, you're still training the audience how to watch the show.
在第二集中，你仍在训练观众如何观看节目。
You're you're you're outlining themes you're showing.
你正在概述你要展示的主题。
This is what our editing is like like you're you're really teaching them the rhythms of how to watch the show.
这就是我们的剪辑就像你在教他们如何观看节目的节奏一样。
And I think one of the satisfying things for people about watching the show is once it clicks in their brain like this is the kind of show I'm watching it's so satisfying because it yeah allows you it makes you do a little bit of work yeah and we like doing a little bit of work oh yeah definitely and you you bet on your most you're creating the show for the audience you want to be watching it and you're you're believing in their intelligence to follow it and trust falling into them and boy did the show find a very intelligent, sophisticated, cool audience.
我认为观看这部剧的人们最满意的事情之一就是，一旦它在他们的大脑中响起，就像我正在观看的那种节目一样，它是如此令人满意，因为它允许你做一点工作，是的，我们喜欢做一点工作，哦，是的，当然，你打赌你在为你想观看的观众创造这个节目，你相信他们的智慧会跟随它并相信他们，男孩，这个节目找到了一个非常好的机会。聪明、老练、冷静的观众。
We're very lucky.
我们很幸运。
We were learning what the show was, too.
我们也在了解这个节目是什么。
I remember the pilot, when we shot the pilot, it was like 10 minutes long.
我记得试播集，当我们拍摄试播集时，大概有10分钟长。
It's supposed to be 22 minutes long.
应该是22分钟长。
It was like 32 minutes long.
好像有32分钟长。
And when we said, we won't make that mistake again, then we shot episode two.
当我们说我们不会再犯同样的错误时，我们就拍摄了第二集。
I think it was 11 minutes long.
我认为它有11分钟长。
It was so, it was like even longer, because we just overrooted, overshot it, overpacked.
就是这样，甚至更长，因为我们只是过度扎根，过度过度，过度包装。
That's why John Brinfall has so little to do.
这就是约翰·布林法尔无事可做的原因。
He's such a great actor.
他是一位很棒的演员。
He went on to become this huge star.
他后来成为了这位巨星。
He's great.
他很棒。
He used to have more bits about Carlos Carlos would have there were jokes.
他曾经有更多关于卡洛斯的事情，卡洛斯希望有笑话。
I remember up on that roof, there was like a top piece with Carlos and Robin totally all so much of it got condensed.
我记得在那个屋顶上，有一个卡洛斯和罗宾的顶级作品，所有的东西都被浓缩了。
He's still funny at it and has a good couple of good moments.
他仍然很有趣，并且有很多美好的时刻。
But I remember thinking, I'll pour John Bernthal, the victim of us completely overriding and oversteeding this episode.
但我记得我当时想，我会把约翰·伯恩塔尔（John Bernthal）倒在他身上，他是我们完全凌驾于这一集之上和过度控制的受害者。
And I remember we had to get in at it and just boom, boom, boom, just really crunch it down and that that was us still learning how to make it week to week, how to make this.
我记得我们必须投入其中，然后就是繁荣，繁荣，繁荣，只是真正地把它压垮，而我们仍然在学习如何一周又一周地做到这一点，如何做到这一点。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
You know, I'm sure when I first watched it, you're so alert to what's been cut.
你知道，我确信当我第一次看它时，你对被删减的内容非常警惕。
Like your first, your first watch is an actor is like, oh, they cut that, they cut that joke or that line.
就像你的第一部作品一样，你的第一部作品是一个演员，哦，他们剪掉了那个，他们剪掉了那个笑话或那句台词。
And then 20 years on, you're like, I have no idea what was lost in that episode.
20 年后，你会想，我不知道在那一集中失去了什么。
Yeah, I, that's 100% true.
是的，我，这100%是真的。
I was trying to remember, but I knew I knew I know stuff got cut, but I kind of forgot.
我试图回忆，但我知道我知道我知道东西被剪掉了，但我有点忘记了。
Maybe that means it was the right move to cut it.
也许这意味着削减它是正确的举措。
And certainly timing wise, we had to.
当然，从时间上来说，我们必须这样做。
Can I clarify here because Edlund.jo represents many people who ask the question, why a purple giraffe?
我可以在这里澄清一下，因为 Edlund.jo 代表了很多提出这个问题的人，为什么是紫色长颈鹿？
So I'm sorry, can you clarify, which came first?
抱歉，您能澄清一下，哪个先出现吗？
We knew we wanted there to be some item.
我们知道我们想要有一些东西。
We wanted to go off of this metaphor because they're really are, and to this day every year, if you search it, there's multiple times a year a little kid crawls up into the game machine and the claw machine and get stuck.
我们想摆脱这个比喻，因为它们确实如此，每年直到今天，如果你搜索它，一年中会有好几次一个小孩子爬进游戏机和抓娃娃机并被卡住。
It happens with frequency.
它经常发生。
Like it really does.
确实如此。
People send it to me now.
人们现在将其发送给我。
Like we used to see these stories in Carter and I would laugh about them and we said this is what Ted's doing.
就像我们以前在卡特身上看到这些故事一样，我会嘲笑它们，我们说这就是特德所做的。
He's trying to crawl up into the machine.
他正试图爬进机器里。
He's trying to skip the steps and we said we made a whole episode based on that metaphor combined with this Gatsby idea of the parties, the lure, the girl and that was the big idea.
他试图跳过这些步骤，我们说我们根据这个隐喻制作了一整集，并结合了盖茨比关于派对、诱惑、女孩的想法，这就是一个伟大的想法。
But so we knew we needed it to be an item so we said what's the item I said, well, let's make it a purple giraffe for my wife's favorite color and favorite animal and I figured I would steal it.
但我们知道我们需要它成为一个物品，所以我们说我说的物品是什么，好吧，让我们把它做成一只紫色长颈鹿，作为我妻子最喜欢的颜色和最喜欢的动物，我想我会偷它。
And again, here it is to this day, if you don't know this show, everyone, if you're listening is also on YouTube.
再说一次，直到今天，如果你不知道这个节目，每个人，如果你正在听的话，也在 YouTube 上。
And if you were watching on YouTube, you now could see Craig's purple giraffe, purple, you have purple giraffe, you have the blue French horn.
如果你在 YouTube 上观看，你现在可以看到克雷格的紫色长颈鹿，紫色，你有紫色长颈鹿，你有蓝色法国号。
In the first two episodes, you're setting up these iconic objects.
在前两集中，您将设置这些标志性对象。
And I've seen, there's been a lot of how I made your mother art over the years that gets sent to me where it's just like yellow umbrella, Blue French horn, red cowboy boots, like there's just these items that are so associated with the show, pineapples.
我已经看到，这些年来我制作你母亲艺术的很多东西都被发送给我，就像黄色的雨伞、蓝色的圆号、红色的牛仔靴，就像这些与演出如此相关的物品，菠萝。
I think, like, were you guys consciously trying to create this glossary of items that would be, or do you guys just like metaphor, like, where does that come from?
我想，就像，你们是有意识地试图创建这个项目术语表，还是你们只是喜欢隐喻，比如，它从哪里来？
Yeah, I think we were conscious of, like, wanting to have these iconic things.
是的，我认为我们有意识地想要拥有这些标志性的东西。
I think it was pretty conscious.
我认为这是非常有意识的。
I mean, where these music nerds, kind of like looking at the cover of Sergeant Peppers and noticing new things each time, you know what I mean?
我的意思是，这些音乐迷就像看着《佩珀斯中士》的封面，每次都会注意到新事物，你知道我的意思吗？
We wanted this vast array, this sort of menagerie of visual things and distinctive, memorable things.
我们想要这种巨大的阵列，这种视觉事物和独特的、令人难忘的事物的动物园。
And Carter, I think Carter was really especially good at that.
卡特，我认为卡特在这方面真的特别擅长。
He was good at realizing it should be this color, it should be that color.
他很擅长意识到应该是这种颜色，应该是那种颜色。
I think Purple Draft came from a shout out to my wife, but who was the inspiration for Billy, and we wanted to honor her in episode two for lending some of her life and herself to this a little bit.
我认为《紫色草稿》来自于对我妻子的呼喊，但她是《比利》的灵感来源，我们想在第二集中向她致敬，因为她为这部电影贡献了一些她的生活和她自己。
But it's true.
但这是真的。
Once we had a blue French horn and a purple giraffe, it was kind of like, well, we have to keep finding these things, these memorable items, these sort of talismans along the way.
一旦我们有了一只蓝色的法国号和一只紫色的长颈鹿，我们就必须一路寻找这些东西，这些令人难忘的物品，这些护身符。
We sort of looked at it like almost like in a map, you know, like an old, like, an ancient map that has, like, there'd be dragons here, and there's a little picture of a dragon And just like along the way you will find these things, there will be these colorful, interesting markers along the way on this map of this journey.
我们几乎就像在地图上一样看它，你知道，就像一张古老的地图，上面有龙，还有一张龙的小图片，就像沿途你会发现这些东西一样，在这次旅程的地图上沿途会有这些色彩缤纷、有趣的标记。
And just like a great, like, ancient, illustrated map, that's the image that it comes to me.
就像一张伟大的、古老的、带插图的地图一样，这就是我想到的图像。
Just along the way, you will find these markers.
一路上，您会发现这些标记。
And the markers will be memorable and indelible.
这些标记将令人难忘且不可磨灭。
And that was kind of the things you keep with you in your memory and your life story.
这就是你在记忆和生活故事中保留的东西。
I love it.
我喜欢它。
I mean, it's almost like the Oracle says, gather these three things, and you will...
我的意思是，这几乎就像神谕所说的那样，收集这三件事，你就会......
Yeah.
是的。
a D&D candidate.
D&D 候选人。
It's like you must find the yellow umbrella and the blue French horn and there'll be a purple giraffe.
就像你必须找到黄色的雨伞和蓝色的法国号一样，就会有一只紫色的长颈鹿。
You must find the purple giraffe.
你必须找到紫色长颈鹿。
It kind of came from that mythic place almost, yeah.
它几乎来自那个神秘的地方，是的。
Like that one or the show had its own mythology.
就像那个或那个节目有它自己的神话一样。
These are just a couple things, one that I found delightful.
这些只是我发现令人愉快的几件事。
One of my favorite things, I always love my cool architecture tools.
我最喜欢的事情之一，我一直喜欢我很酷的架构工具。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
I just love it.
我就是喜欢它。
It's so goofy and it's also are like so clear, like I don't know what these are for.
它是如此愚蠢，但也如此清晰，就像我不知道这些是做什么用的。
It really seems like can't, may not be an architect.
看来确实不行，可能不是建筑师。
He might not be an architect.
他可能不是建筑师。
It's like this is cool.
好像这很酷。
I love when he says whatever, like to Robin, like try to be casual, whatever, yeah, just the faux casual is so funny from a not casual dude.
我喜欢他说的任何话，就像对罗宾说的那样，比如尝试变得随意，无论如何，是的，只是一个不随意的家伙说的假随意就很有趣。
He's the, yeah, a mushroom cloud of casual, so he describes himself earlier, the least casual image.
是的，他是休闲的蘑菇云，所以他之前描述自己时，是最不休闲的形象。
Yeah.
是的。
What was also when Robin cost so that was Robin.
当罗宾付出代价时，这也是罗宾。
That's a funny runner.
这是一个有趣的跑步者。
Robin that has a lot of good runners that episode.
罗宾那集有很多优秀的跑步者。
It's really really a sort of groundhog day.
这确实是土拨鼠日。
Like the more I think about it, I don't remember thinking of it in the moment when we were making it, but it's, right?
就像我想得越多，我不记得在我们制作它的那一刻想到过它，但它是，对吧？
He's, I remember that montage in Groundhog Day where he's trying to recreate this amazing moment.
他，我记得《土拨鼠之日》中的那个蒙太奇，他试图重现这个令人惊叹的时刻。
They do manage to have an amazing moment somewhere along the way.
他们确实在一路上的某个地方度过了一段美妙的时刻。
And the day that he has an Andy McDowell and I try to recreate it and get some more forced and distorted and terrible the more you try to recreate it and make it perfect and it's that's what this is a little bit.
当他拥有安迪·麦克道威尔的那一天，我尝试重新创造它，你越尝试重新创造它并使其完美，就会变得更加强迫、扭曲和可怕，这就是这件事的一点点。
One thing and this is a good lead into Jordana but I realized on the roof and I don't even know if attachment theory or attachment language was invoked in 2005.
有一件事，这是进入 Jordana 的一个很好的线索，但我在屋顶上意识到，我什至不知道 2005 年是否引用了依恋理论或依恋语言。
I don't think it was that much but it's very clear that Ted has an anxious attachment style and Robin has an an avoidant attachment style, and avoidant and anxious people often find each other.
我不认为有那么多，但很明显，泰德有焦虑型依恋风格，罗宾有回避型依恋风格，回避型和焦虑型的人经常会找到对方。
It's actually like a weirdly good dysfunctional kind of hook, you know, the two of them, but heads kind of like needy, anxious, like he needs proof of love, he needs, he gets very, you know, he needs a little too much, right?
这实际上就像一个奇怪的、功能失调的钩子，你知道，他们两个，但头脑有点像需要帮助，焦虑，就像他需要爱的证明，他需要，他变得非常，你知道，他需要一点太多，对吧？
And Robin is a little like, you're too much.
罗宾有点像，你太过分了。
And she needs distance because she fears being engulfed and he fears being abandoned.
她需要距离，因为她害怕被吞没，而他害怕被抛弃。
Yeah.
是的。
dynamic is so at play and into it and that is an ancient that is a dynamic you can spend another 200 episodes figuring out yeah and we did and we didn't know at the time we would do that but you there's it's a deep well it's a deep reservoir yeah the other the other big thematic thing that started to become really clear to me there's this Jungian concept of the puer which means the eternal child.
动态是如此地发挥作用，这是一个古老的动态，你可以再花200集弄清楚是的，我们做到了，我们当时不知道我们会这样做，但你那里有一口深井，它是一个深水库，是的，另一个大主题对我来说开始变得非常清楚，那就是荣格的“普儿”概念，意味着永恒的孩子。
And Ted has this youthful child like, yeah, I mean, he wants to be a man.
特德有一个年轻的孩子，是的，我的意思是，他想成为一个男人。
He's, he's, he wants the trappings of man who he wants to house.
他，他，他想要他想要安置的男人的服饰。
He wants a career.
他想要一份事业。
He wants a wife and children like he wants, he ostensibly wants all these things.
他想要一个妻子和孩子，就像他想要的那样，表面上他想要所有这些东西。
But his motor and his kind of world view is childish in certain ways.
但他的动力和世界观在某些方面是幼稚的。
And it feels to me like the, the arc of him throughout the series is like, it's watching someone become a man, you know, it's really watching someone learn how to be whole within themselves, not walk around with this kind of like, are you my mother?
在我看来，他在整个系列中的弧线就像是，看着一个人成为一个男人，你知道，这真的是看着一个人学会如何成为一个完整的人，而不是带着这样的样子走来走去，你是我的母亲吗？
Are you my mother?
你是我妈妈吗？
Are you, you know, it's kind of like this mother hunger?
你知道，这有点像母亲的饥饿吗？
Like, like, I mean, I didn't even mean that as a public title.
就像，就像，我的意思是，我什至不是说这是一个公共标题。
But it works.
但它有效。
There is something about him that is just, um, he cannot sit still.
他身上有一些东西，嗯，他不能安静地坐着。
He cannot be in the present moment without needing to adjust the knobs of the present moment and engineer it a little bit more towards where he thinks he's supposed to go.
他不可能活在当下，而不需要调整当下的旋钮，并将其设计得更接近他认为自己应该去的地方。
And it's really about watching for 208 episodes of man, a young man get foiled over and over and over again until he surrenders.
这实际上是关于观看 208 集男人的故事，一个年轻人一次又一次地被挫败，直到他投降。
And then it happens.
然后事情就发生了。
Yeah, it's that thing you've talked about of like the need and the gift of being humiliated.
是的，这就是你谈到的东西，比如被羞辱的需要和礼物。
It's actually sort of a gift you sort of need to go through this crucible, it's a path you have to walk and survive.
这实际上是一种你需要经历这个严峻考验的礼物，这是你必须行走和生存的道路。
And they say in the Western world, men do not have initiatory, this is really getting in the weeds, folks, but women have this very natural initiatory thing that happens to their bodies when they have their period, right?
他们说，在西方世界，男人没有主动性，这真的是在杂草中，伙计们，但女性有这种非常自然的主动性，当她们来月经时，她们的身体就会发生这种情况，对吗？
It's an actual, there's a before and after.
这是真实的，有前后。
What's that?
那是什么？
I'm going to, I'm going to text you right now, I'm going to give you some links.
我现在就给你发短信，我会给你一些链接。
Okay.
好的。
But can we sign by about that?
但我们可以就此签字吗？
Because that's not important.
因为那并不重要。
But, but men don't have that.
但是，但是男人没有这个。
Like we don't have that kind of, so in, in, in other cultures, there's these initiatory things with men and they say that if men aren't taught, if men aren't humiliated in a safe context with, with, with an initiatory kind of thing, they will misuse power when they get power.
就像我们没有那样的东西一样，所以在其他文化中，男性也有这些主动性的事情，他们说，如果男人没有受到教育，如果男人没有在安全的环境中受到主动性的事情的羞辱，他们在获得权力时就会滥用权力。
And I think we see that, you know, you see that people who have power misuse it because they don't understand what it's like to be low, you know, so you need to be brought low so that when you have power, you know how to use it responsibly.
我认为我们看到，你知道，你看到拥有权力的人滥用权力，因为他们不明白地位低下是什么感觉，所以你需要被降低，这样当你拥有权力时，你知道如何负责任地使用它。
So yeah, it feels to me like this show is an initiatory for this character.
所以，是的，我觉得这部剧是这个角色的开始。
Yeah.
是的。
Oh yeah, absolutely.
哦，是的，绝对是。
And I loved the compliment you for I love the kind of live wire energy you had in this.
我喜欢你的赞美，因为我喜欢你在这方面所拥有的那种充满活力的能量。
So you almost had like a, like good fellas, like the montage where he's cooking the meatballs and the helicopters are chasing him.
所以你几乎就像一个好家伙一样，就像他正在煮肉丸而直升机在追他的蒙太奇一样。
He's unmounted.
他已经下马了。
He's just doing so many things like you had like this grade almost kind of coked up energy running around in this episode and it's like, so that was probably me as an actor being pretty amped up to be starring in a television show.
他只是做了很多像你一样的事情，就像这个年级在这一集里几乎有点焦躁的能量，所以这可能是我作为一个演员对主演电视节目感到非常兴奋。
I used it.
我用过。
I used that kind of energy of like, ah, yeah.
我用了那种能量，啊，是的。
felt so young and so alive and so like it was very compelling to watch.
感觉自己如此年轻，如此充满活力，看起来非常引人注目。
It was just like this buzzing live wire.
就像这条嗡嗡作响的火线。
He really was like shot out of a cannon in that episode and you really inhabited that.
在那一集中，他真的就像是从大炮中射出的，而你也确实身处其中。
I think we, I think without meaning to, we tapped into actually how we all felt.
我认为我们，我认为无意中，我们实际上利用了我们所有人的感受。
It's episode two.
已经是第二集了
It's gotta be good.
一定很好。
We gotta, we gotta go, go, go.
我们必须，我们必须走，走，走。
And it feels that we got it through the best party.
感觉我们通过最好的聚会得到了它。
We got it through the best party and we're gonna throw fucking three of them and they're gonna make no sense, but we're gonna do it.
我们通过了最好的派对，我们要扔掉他们三个，他们毫无意义，但我们会这么做。
And we're, yeah, we're inviting you to that party and it's gonna last longer than you think.
是的，我们邀请您参加那个聚会，而且它的持续时间比您想象的要长。
I think it became a metaphor for the whole thing.
我认为这成为了整个事情的隐喻。
I also did like Barney's romance with that Carlos's friend.
我也很喜欢巴尼和卡洛斯的朋友的浪漫。
I think he's kind of upset about it.
我想他对此有点不高兴。
He's better because yeah, it's not going to work.
他更好了，因为是的，这是行不通的。
That's a terrible idea.
这是一个糟糕的主意。
They work together.
他们一起工作。
Yeah.
是的。
Barney had a bunch.
巴尼有一堆。
I mean, everyone had good stuff in that one, and it really makes the sale of how Robin joined the group.
我的意思是，每个人都有好东西，这确实让罗宾如何加入这个团队变得更有意义。
But it really is a great TED episode.
但这确实是一个很棒的 TED 节目。
It really gets under the hood and shows you who you just watched and the pilot and what the dilemmas are going to be moving forward.
它真正深入幕后，向您展示您刚刚观看的人物、试播集以及接下来将面临的困境。
Even the gift Robin gives back to Ted, they have you met Ted, where do you even start looking?
即使是罗宾回馈给泰德的礼物，他们也见过泰德，你从哪里开始寻找呢？
And she becomes his wingman or his co-wingman there along with Tony and you realize that's another move of the show.
她和托尼一起成为他的僚机或他的搭档，你意识到这是这部剧的另一个动作。
It's a great, it's a great final scene in the bar.
太棒了，酒吧里的最后一幕很棒。
I love the final scene.
我喜欢最后的场景。
I felt very moved by it.
我对此感到非常感动。
I mean, a lot of them are making me want to cry while we're watching and just how wonderful it.
我的意思是，当我们观看时，其中很多都让我想哭，这真是太棒了。
And shooting those scenes and realizing this works.
拍摄这些场景并实现这个作品。
I want to see next week's episode.
我想看下周的剧集。
I want to see this dynamic unfold.
我希望看到这种动态的展开。
I think it made the sale, I hope so.
我认为它成功了，我希望如此。
I remember being very scared about that episode.
我记得我对那一集感到非常害怕。
So it was good to go back and watch it and be like, it's pretty good.
所以很高兴回去观看并感叹，这非常好。
And just so everyone knows of like how much Josh and Craig are enjoying this as though they haven't seen it, they're texting, we're texting each other.
就像每个人都知道的那样，乔什和克雷格有多喜欢这个，就好像他们没有看到一样，他们在发短信，我们也在互相发短信。
And I just, I just much preferable giraffe.
我只是，我更喜欢长颈鹿。
It was so funny when I had watched it in years, years enjoying this in the moment.
当我多年来观看它时，这真是太有趣了，多年来享受这一刻。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And someone who I think is enjoying at the moment who has never seen it is of course Josh was wife Jordana who Josh is there a name for this segment of a show I've lost track of the name of this.
我认为目前正在享受但从未见过的人当然是乔什（Josh），他的妻子乔丹娜（Jordana），乔什（Josh）是节目中这一段的名字，我已经不记得这个节目的名字了。
I mean I had you say it was something like questions and observations from clinical psychologists and relationship expert who's never seen how I met your mother who also happens to be married to Josh.
我的意思是，我让你说，这类似于临床心理学家和关系专家的问题和观察，他们从未见过我是如何认识你母亲的，而你母亲恰好也嫁给了乔什。
And that acronym is Josh is for people.
Josh 是“人”的缩写。
I can't do it.
我做不到。
We'll get it out.
我们会把它弄出来。
Yeah.
是的。
music behind it also.
背后的音乐也。
Well, she, she watched episode two, Purple Draft, and let's see what was on her mind.
嗯,她,她看了第二集,紫草,看看她在想什么。
So I was really taken this episode with how gracefully Ted handled rejection.
所以这一集我真的很喜欢特德如何优雅地处理拒绝。
He didn't get angry at Robin.
他没有对罗宾生气。
He didn't devalue her.
他并没有贬低她。
Instead, he just accepted that a romantic connection was not in the cards in the moment.
相反，他只是接受了目前不可能建立浪漫关系的事实。
And I think this hits on probably like a himium theme that when it comes to love, timing is everything.
我认为这可能就像一个主题，当谈到爱情时，时机就是一切。
And I think more generally, it implies that if we can accept things as they are, not as we'd like them to be, then we allow for the unfolding of something so much more beautiful than we could have ever imagined.
我认为更一般地说，这意味着如果我们能够接受事物的本来面目，而不是我们希望它们成为的样子，那么我们就会允许一些比我们想象的更美丽的事物展开。
That's wonderful.
太棒了。
That's a, that I love that interpretation so much.
那是，我非常喜欢这种解释。
Josh, you got a good one.
乔什，你有一个很好的。
You hold onto that girl.
你抓住那个女孩。
You treat her right.
你对待她是对的。
very smart analysis.
非常聪明的分析。
I love that acceptance piece.
我喜欢那篇接受作品。
I know I had never really considered it, but I actually thought of more of like what's going on now with men and just this idea that like women don't owe you anything.
我知道我从来没有真正考虑过这一点，但实际上我更多地想到了现在男人身上发生的事情，以及女人不欠你任何东西的想法。
You're not owed sex.
你不欠性。
You're not owed their attention.
你不值得他们的关注。
You earn it by being a menchie impressive interesting funny person.
你通过成为一个令人印象深刻、有趣、有趣的人来获得它。
And I just like so much that that observation like he really gets rejected by her twice now, you know, or maybe he kind of like takes himself, he kind of rejects himself in the second episode in some way.
我非常喜欢这种观察，就像他现在真的被她拒绝了两次一样，你知道，或者也许他有点喜欢自己，他在第二集中以某种方式拒绝了自己。
It's just knowing that they're not aligned.
只是知道他们不一致。
But there is a grace and a kind of elegance and a, I don't know what the word is, but he really, he takes himself out and he He says, I'm not the guy for this right now because I can't tone it down or turn it off.
但有一种优雅，一种优雅，我不知道这个词是什么，但他真的，他把自己拿出来，他说，我现在不适合这样做，因为我无法减弱或关闭它。
But I think what she's saying is there's something really refreshing about seeing a man not turn around and hate a woman because she doesn't want to be with him or doesn't think it's right.
但我认为她所说的是，看到一个男人不会因为一个女人不想和他在一起或者认为这是不对的而转身恨一个女人，这确实令人耳目一新。
But rather says, why don't you join my friends for a drink in the bar?
而是说，你为什么不和我的朋友一起去酒吧喝一杯呢？
Yeah.
是的。
He was the bigger person there.
他是那里更大的人。
he could have gone a petty way with it.
他本可以对此采取一点小行动。
And when he said, let's wait a few months and just get past the awkwardness of this and then check in, that's reasonable for him to say.
当他说，让我们等几个月，克服这种尴尬，然后再登记入住时，他说的是有道理的。
It was sad to think that that might be how it goes.
想到事情可能就是这样，我感到很难过。
And then when he senses her sadness, because she really does like him.
然后当他感觉到她的悲伤时，因为她真的很喜欢他。
She really does it, thanks for him.
她真的做到了，谢谢他。
And she really liked his friends.
她真的很喜欢他的朋友。
She and Lily had that great bond for him.
她和莉莉对他有着深厚的感情。
You can tell they had chemistry to his friends.
你可以看出他们和他的朋友们有化学反应。
and his invitation, the generosity of his invitation to her to come join their friend group.
还有他的邀请，他慷慨地邀请她加入他们的朋友圈。
I just loved him at that moment and that Jordan is right.
那一刻我就爱他了，乔丹是对的。
That was, that came from a place of acceptance, that came from a place of transcending whatever petty rejection he might have felt.
也就是说，这来自于接受，来自于超越他可能感受到的任何微不足道的拒绝。
And also with Tim saying, I really think this is a good human being and we're supposed to be in each other's lives and she's feeling like a lost soul.
蒂姆也说过，我真的认为这是一个好人，我们应该出现在彼此的生活中，而她感觉就像一个迷失的灵魂。
I wanna bring her into our group.
我想把她拉进我们的队伍。
She said she hasn't met many good people here in New York.
她说她在纽约没遇到多少好人。
I really like the fact that like she's new to New York City, you know, I really like I really felt that in that moment She played that beautifully.
我真的很喜欢这样一个事实，就像她是纽约市的新人一样，你知道，我真的很喜欢我真的感觉到在那一刻她演奏得那么美妙。
It was very vulnerable.
它非常脆弱。
I don't I haven't met many good people And you remember that moment when you first moved to New York in your 20s and you're like it's such a big city How many people when you have it?
我不知道，我没有遇到很多好人，你还记得你20多岁时第一次搬到纽约的那一刻，你就像这是一个大城市，当你有多少人时？
I mean, I kind of had it baked in just because I went right into grad school And I had this community, but I remember in LA it took me a while to you know It takes you a while to find your tribe and big cities especially are incredibly disorienting before you find your neighborhood you love, the community you love, it's, um, and you have to have that.
我的意思是，我有点把它烤熟了，因为我直接进入了研究生院，我有这个社区，但我记得在洛杉矶，我花了一段时间才知道，你需要一段时间才能找到你的部落，而大城市在你找到你喜欢的社区、你喜欢的社区之前，尤其是令人难以置信的迷失方向，它是，嗯，你必须拥有它。
I mean, you can't, big cities are so isolating and it could be so overwhelming.
我的意思是，你不能，大城市是如此孤立，而且可能令人难以承受。
Um, but yeah, I thought, uh, I, I was really taken with that and I think, I think Jordan was also pointing to what we were talking about earlier that, you know, um, I always think, I always think of it like life, like a, like surviving a reptile or undertow, like if you fight The undertow, it takes you down.
嗯，但是，是的，我想，呃，我，我真的对此很着迷，我想，我认为乔丹也指出了我们之前谈论的内容，你知道，嗯，我总是认为，我总是认为它就像生活，就像一个，就像在爬行动物或逆流中生存，就像如果你与逆流战斗，它会把你击倒。
It's really dangerous.
这真的很危险。
But if you let it take you, it pops you back up.
但如果你让它带你走，它就会把你拉回来。
Yeah.
是的。
And it feels like in these first two episodes, Ted, he tries to fight and tries to fight and he's drowning until he just lets it take him, you know, and he pops up and he's doing okay.
感觉就像在前两集中，特德，他试图战斗，试图战斗，但他快要淹死了，直到他任由它带走他，你知道，他突然出现，他做得很好。
We got some great questions about purple giraffe that we weren't able to get to here, but that's why we've got general questions.
我们有一些关于紫色长颈鹿的重要问题，但我们无法在这里提出，但这就是为什么我们有一般性问题。
General questions coming to you in a bonus episode later in the week, FYI, the audio message that you heard at the top of the show was sent in through our website, and you can send in yours too.
一般性问题将在本周晚些时候的奖励剧集中向您提出，仅供参考，您在节目顶部听到的音频消息是通过我们的网站发送的，您也可以发送您的。
Just keep it under 60 seconds, and it might make it on to a future Huimium episode.
只要将其控制在 60 秒以内，它就可能出现在未来的 Huimium 剧集中。
Huimium.
惠米姆。
Go to www.howwemadeyourmother.com and click on contact and share your story with us.
访问 www.howwemadeyourmother.com，点击“联系”并与我们分享您的故事。
On that same contact page, you can also write to us with a story.
在同一联系页面上，您还可以写信给我们讲述故事。
And those are the stories we are reading here at the end of the show.
这些就是我们在节目结束时阅读的故事。
So Craig, why don't you read this first one?
那么克雷格，你为什么不读一下第一篇呢？
This one is from Joe in Birmingham, UK, she says.
她说，这是英国伯明翰的乔寄来的。
Our whole wedding was himium themes.
我们的整个婚礼都是 Himium 主题。
Josh, we hear this a lot too, don't we like the tattoos?
乔什，我们也经常听到这样的说法，我们不喜欢纹身吗？
We hear this.
我们听到这个。
We've heard this so many times.
我们已经听过很多次了。
It's amazing.
太棒了。
Okay.
好的。
Back to the letter.
回到那封信。
We had a blue French horn as the main table centerpiece and blue violins and red roses on the other tables to represent the blue quartet.
我们有一个蓝色的圆号作为主桌子的中心装饰品，其他桌子上有蓝色的小提琴和红色的玫瑰来代表蓝色四重奏。
All the men were ducky ties.
所有的男人都是鸭子领带。
Our first dance was groups in the heart that Barney and Robin did.
我们的第一支舞是巴尼和罗宾跳的《心中的组合》。
I had a yellow umbrella for photos, the bride.
新娘，我有一把黄色的伞，用来拍照。
For our honeymoon, we went to New York and went to McLaren's bar, that the bar that McLaren's is based on called.
为了度蜜月，我们去了纽约，去了迈凯伦酒吧，迈凯伦酒吧的原型就是这个酒吧。
But I think she means, which is McGee's in Midtown, shout out to McGee's.
但我认为她的意思是，这是麦吉在中城的地方，向麦吉大声喊叫。
We had a far-hampton sign too.
我们也有一个远汉普顿的标志。
The guest list was made to look like a playbook, and the table plan was designed like a blueprint by most BS designs.
宾客名单看起来就像是一本剧本，餐桌的设计就像大多数 BS 设计的蓝图一样。
Our son, who was born nine months after our wedding, is called Ted.
我们的儿子是我们结婚九个月后出生的，名叫特德。
And Ted's first birthday, he had bro code t-shirts for him and his brother, and they have a made-up day called Brothers Day, where they hang out together and get each other presents to appreciate each other.
泰德 (Ted) 一岁生日时，他为自己和弟弟制作了兄弟代码 T 恤，他们还特意安排了一个名为“兄弟日”的日子，他们一起出去玩，互相赠送礼物以表达对彼此的感激之情。
It's on the Sunday before Valentine's Day, because Hashtag grows before hose.
这是在情人节前的周日，因为标签先于软管生长。
See, you're teaching your son some really good lessons that he shouldn't show up, I don't know.
你看，你正在给你儿子上一些非常好的课，但我不知道他不应该出现。
That story is beautiful.
那个故事很美。
Amazing.
惊人的。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Ted was born nine months after the wedding.
婚礼九个月后，特德出生了。
That was a hell of a wedding night.
那真是一个糟糕的新婚之夜。
To one hell of a wedding.
一场地狱般的婚礼。
What a wedding.
真是一场婚礼啊。
That is an honor that you guys made your wedding him you seemed and the granularity the number of good ideas and ways you integrated it really impressive.
你们为他举办的婚礼是一种荣幸，你们所提出的好想法的数量和方式的精细程度令人印象深刻。
And if you're watching this on YouTube or want to check out our sub stack page, yes, we're going to share right now the far Hampton sign from Joe's wedding.
如果您正在 YouTube 上观看此内容或想查看我们的子堆栈页面，是的，我们现在将分享乔婚礼上远处的汉普顿标志。
Oh, these are pictures of the wedding.
哦，这些是婚礼照片。
We have pictures from the wedding.
我们有婚礼的照片。
There's the Blue French Horn.
那里有蓝色圆号。
Oh, that's great.
哦，那太好了。
There's the guest book, the guest book, and there's a little, there's Ted, the name of their son Ted nine months after the wedding.
有留言簿，留言簿，还有一点，就是泰德，婚礼九个月后他们儿子泰德的名字。
It's what?
是啥啊？
What in Josh?
乔什呢？
Can you believe that?
你能相信吗？
Did 2005 you think there was going to be a baby named Ted that people are having weddings and like, no, you know, there's a lot of dogs named Mosby.
2005 年，你是否认为会有一个名叫特德 (Ted) 的婴儿，人们正在举办婚礼，并且，不，你知道，有很多名叫莫斯比 (Mosby) 的狗。
Let's be a good name for a dog.
让我们为狗起一个好名字。
Very loyal.
非常忠诚。
That's some shares and trades with Ted.
这是与特德的一些股票和交易。
This is from Chelsea in Durham, North Carolina.
这是来自北卡罗来纳州达勒姆的切尔西。
I'll try to keep this short just like Ted did.
我会像特德一样尽量保持简短。
I met my wife at summer camp when we were 15.
我15岁时在夏令营认识了我的妻子。
She came out our senior year of high school and then we both went to the same college.
她从我们高中高年级毕业，然后我们都去了同一所大学。
I came out my sophomore year of college and then we started dating.
我大学二年级毕业，然后我们开始约会。
We dated on and off from 2013 to 2017 when we finally got engaged.
从 2013 年到 2017 年，我们断断续续地约会，最终订婚了。
It was a difficult will they or won't they several years.
几年来，他们是否愿意，这都是一个艰难的决定。
We were broken up when I graduated from college and that summer I binge watched how I met your mother for the first time.
当我大学毕业时，我们分手了，那个夏天我疯狂地观看了我第一次见到你母亲的过程。
speech about what love is to Jeanette summed up how I felt about my wife in a way I was never able to put into words.
关于珍妮特的爱是什么的演讲以一种我无法用语言表达的方式总结了我对我妻子的感受。
I kept my love for my wife even when we weren't in each other's lives.
即使我们不在彼此的生活中，我仍保持对妻子的爱。
We finally found the right time with our right person in 2017.
2017年，我们终于找到了对的时间，和对的人。
We got married in 2019 and have been ridiculously happy together since then.
我们于 2019 年结婚，从那时起我们就过着幸福快乐的生活。
I did tell her she had to watch how I met your mother before we got married.
我确实告诉她，在我们结婚之前，她必须看看我是如何认识你母亲的。
It wasn't her typical type of TV show but she loved it.
这不是她典型的电视节目类型，但她喜欢它。
She said she understood me a bit better after watching my favorite show.
她说看了我最喜欢的节目后她更了解我了。
We didn't share our wedding vows with each other beforehand.
我们事先没有互相宣读结婚誓言。
My vows included Marshall's renewal vows from season 9.
我的誓言包括第九季中马歇尔的更新誓言。
My wife's vows included a promise to always watch how I met your mother with me.
我妻子的誓言包括承诺永远和我一起观看我是如何遇见你母亲的。
Without planning it, we both included this magical story in our wedding.
我们无意中把这个神奇的故事纳入了我们的婚礼。
Chelsea, thank you for that.
切尔西，谢谢你。
Yeah, that's beautiful.
是的，那很漂亮。
Thank you.
谢谢。
That's lovely.
太可爱了。
So happy to show meant that to you guys.
很高兴向大家展示这一点。
I think couples that watch how I met that your mother together stayed together.
我认为那些看着我如何认识你母亲的情侣们会一直在一起。
That's just a truism.
这只是一个不言而喻的道理。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
All sins off again.
一切罪孽再次消散。
New York City.
纽约市。
How we made your mother is hosted an executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯担任执行制片人主持。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作。
And our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Pointe de Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Pointe de Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）创作的《NYC》。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connards.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳德。
Visit howwemajormother.com to sign up for our sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 howwemajormother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Riders' Muse Letters on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Riders 的 Muse Letters。
Read Craig Thomas' Published Pros at CraigThomasRider.com, and you can subscribe to my Dead Father Society, also on Substack.
在 CraigThomasRider.com 上阅读克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 发表的专业文章，您还可以订阅我的《已故父亲协会》(Dead Father Society)，该协会也在 Substack 上。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of backyard ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持和 Tink Media 的营销支持下得以实现的。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
Real question.
真正的问题。
It just hit me.
它刚刚击中了我。
Am I in love or just new York City?
我恋爱了还是只是纽约市？